bien mes chers collègues bonjour on va
démarrer
cette journée assez longue puisque je
rappelle que ce matin au delà de
l'audition conjointe de nos amis
représentants l'abbé TD nous
continuerons par l'examen de et le vote
de plusieurs projets de loi
a provenant des accords internationaux
et cet après-midi je rappelle que nous
avons l'audition de la ministre des
Affaires étrangères à l'issue des
questions au gouvernement
mais si les présidents nous poursuivons
donc nos auditions sur la loi de
programmation militaire en prenant le
temps d'entendre ce matin les présidents
des trois principaux groupements
relatifs
représentatifs des industries de défense
marque Darmon qui préside le J4 pour ce
qui est des industries terrestres aéro
terrestres Guillaume Faury qui va
arriver
président du GIFAS pour la filière
aéronautique et spatiale et
pierre-éricommelet président du GICAN
pour les industries navales
merci messieurs de vous être rendu
disponible sur le même créneau horaire
ce qui est évidemment plus facile et
d'être présent ce matin donc pour
répondre aux différentes interrogations
de nos collègues comme vous le savez la
loi de programmation militaire est
structurante pour l'avenir de la base
industrielle et technologique de défense
qui est au cœur de l'excellent
scientifique et technologique et donc
bien évidemment de la souveraineté de
notre pays le projet de LPM prévoit une
augmentation très significative des
crédits de 168 milliards d'euros
programmés pour les équipements dont 100
milliards d'euros pour les programmes à
effet majeur ceci en fait augmentent de
70% ce qui est considérable même si
évidemment l'inflation introduit une
variable assez forte
ces augmentations globales
s'accompagnent paradoxalement de mesures
significatives d'étalement portant sur
de nombreux programmes au motifs de
privilégier la cohérence sur la masse
vous nous direz s'ils font en déduire
que la LPM actuel est insuffisamment
cohérente
comment se traduit ce principe de
cohérence sur l'équilibre entre vos
activités de production et vous
activités de maintenance aux éclairages
seront évidemment précieux à ce sujet
par ailleurs nous avons été étonnés
d'apprendre que les industriels étaient
appelés à financer en amont sur leur
propre trésorerie une partie du
programme de porte-avion de nouvelle
génération soit d'après la presse un
milliard d'euros sur les 5 milliards
programmés par la LPM nous interrogeons
évidemment sur le coup d'un tel montage
et sur ces répercussions sur le coût
total du porte-avion et vous nous direz
si quelles sont les conséquences de
cette approche pour l'industrie alors
qu'il semble que d'autres programmes
pourraient faire l'objet de démarches
similaires de façon plus générale
quelles sont les reculs quels sont les
reports ou encore quelles sont les paris
à l'export qui vous paraissent les plus
préoccupants et leurs conséquences sur
votre activité industrielle tant pour
les grands groupes que pour les très
nombreux PME et et
qui sont impliqués dans les supply chain
le ministère des armées a entrepris à la
demande du Président de la République
une démarche de simplification et
d'accélération des programmes dites
économie de guerre appellation qui peut
surprendre un peu au regard de ce que ce
terme désigne en général est-ce qu'on
peut aller plus loin dans ce domaine
quels sont vos préconisations est-ce
qu'il y a des limites à vos capacités de
production qui justifierait de revoir à
la base l'ambition 2030 portée par la
LPM actuelle il y avait eu un effet il y
a quelques temps des affirmations sur
lequel le ralentissement du calendrier
de production d'un certain nombre de
d'équipements étaient liés à votre
incapacité à produire ce qui avait du
Ressuscité parmi les industriels
quelques quelques réactions contrastées
alors je vais vous donner la parole pour
10 minutes chacun je vous demande
véritablement de tenir ce de tenir ce
cet horaire
donc après vos trois présentations il y
aura un échange avec les différents
rapporteurs et nos collègues dans le
temps qui nous sera impartis puisque je
l'ai dit après un programme
d'approbation d'accord internationaux
que je dois aussi
mettre en discussion ce matin je vous
précise que c'est audition est captée
elle est retransmise sur le site
internet du Sénat et donc vous aurez la
possibilité ainsi de passer des messages
non seulement au sénateur mais à ceux
qui par hasard
serait devant leur ordinateur ou leur
télévision donc si vous voulez bien je
vais donner la parole par ordre
alphabétique à Marc Darmon qui préside
le J4 puis Guillaume Faury président du
diface et ses pierres Eric Pommelet
place de chicane qui clôturera voilà
c'est le président d'Armand vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président mais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci beaucoup
de votre de votre temps pour cette
audition donc nous sommes là pour donner
la représentation nationale afin des
éléments compréhension vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président sur la loi de
programmation militaire qui définit et
qui va définir notre politique de
défense et aussi la dynamique de
l'industrie de défense pour beaucoup de
temps dans un contexte de guerre au port
de l'Europe vous le savez vous l'avez
dit les enjeux de cette LPM vont en fait
largement au-delà de la décennie je
voudrais donner des éléments avec trois
axes le premier c'est la visibilité la
recherche et développement et
l'innovation et l'exportation d'abord je
commence par quelques mots beaucoup
d'entre vous nous connaissent mais
d'autres non quelques mots sur
l'industrie d'armement terrestre et à
travers le logis 4 que je représente
nous représentons à 400 adhérents c'est
95% des adhérents qui sont des PME des
ETI et des start-up c'est l'ensemble en
haut de la défense à trois exceptions
près d'association naval Group et Ariane
groupe mais toutes les autres toutes les
autres grands groupes sont présents dans
l'industrie terrestre aéro terrestre
c'est près de 50 000 emplois soit à peu
près 20% de la de l'abbaye TD ce sont
comme le reste de la base industrielle
de défense des emplois qui sont très peu
délocalisables de très hautes
technicités extrêmement qualifiées du
technicien spécialisé à l'ingénieur près
de 9 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et plus de 40% réalisé à
l'exportation j'y reviendrai dans le
domaine vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président terrestre de l'industrie
terrestre érotérestre on couvre
l'ensemble de ce que veut dire y compris
bien sûr les besoins interarmés le chant
de la lutte dans le cyberespace le champ
numérique et l'équipement des forces
spéciales et des forces de renseignement
le J4 est important que je le dise le J4
organise aussi le salon Eurosatory qui
est le plus grand salon au monde dans le
domaine de l'industrie terrestre qui a
eu lieu en 2022 et vous êtes invité
évidemment en juin 2024 tous très
largement c'est un salon très important
qui a réuni qui a 1800 exposants
250 délégations de près de 100 pays nous
avons la chance avec Eurosatory pour
l'armée terre euro naval organisé par
logican et le Bourget organisé par logif
face d'avoir en France les trois plus
grands salons dans ce domaine là au
monde le J4 organise aussi et je le cite
les équivalents africains chiffres
d'africain et latino-américain expo
défenseur et nous organisons aussi le
Pavillon France dans deux très grandes
expositions au Moyen-Orient à hydex aux
Émirats et à edex au Caire dans lequel
nous aidons notamment ceux qui ne
peuvent pas avoir de stands parce que
trop petit à être présent sur le
pavillon France
je vais maintenant au à nos trois
priorités telles qu'elles sont
issues de ce que l'on voit dans le cadre
de la loi de programmation militaire
2024 2030 donc d'abord là la visibilité
est extrêmement importante une des
caractéristiques de notre de notre base
industrielle c'est que une bonne partie
de nos PME ETI ne sont pas seulement
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement des
grands métro d'oeuvre mais sont beaucoup
en contact et en contrat direct avec
l'administration contenu de la largeur
du spectre de ce que nous livrons pour
l'équipement du soldat pour la
logistique et pour le génie pour la
santé beaucoup de nos fournisseurs les
PME les ETI ne sont pas seulement des
sous-traitants des grands maîtres d'or
mais sont aussi des des gens qui sont en
contact direct et eux ont besoin de
visibilité directement et pas seulement
à travers les grands maîtres d'oeuvre le
conflit en Ukraine je crois a montré là
la centralité du combat terrestre avec
plusieurs caractéristiques particulières
évidemment la destruction et l'attrition
et donc le besoin de remplacement
de rechange et du soutien
continuellement pour être efficace
l'arrivée de nouveaux domaines on le
voit bien autour des drones tactiques
des munitions téléopérée ou même tout
simplement de l'importance du feu dans
la profondeur
les industriels que soient les grands
métro d'oeuvre et les PME ce sont
structurés autour du besoin de BD de
combat ou d'économie de guerre tel que
vous l'avez cité monsieur le Président
et évidemment une loi de programmation
militaire qui anticipe un effort dans la
durée pour la défense et pour les
provenants sont bien sûr un motif de
satisfaction d'ailleurs une loi de
programmation militaire telle qu'elle
est structurée de nos prémis de nombreux
pays nous l'envie
évidemment les sommes conséquentes qui
sont prévues jusqu'en 2030 sont un
signal fort c'est aussi un signal fort
pour nos clients l'exportation pour pour
nos partenaires ça donne évidemment une
crédibilité stratégique industrielle
alors vous l'avez dit vous-même
évidemment il faut être vigilant le
budget il est défini aujourd'hui en
euros courant et pas en euros constant
nos besoins de prise en compte de
l'inflation et puis on le sait bien
au-delà de 2027 ce qui est un horizon
qui dépasse le projet de loi de finances
programmation des finances publiques le
Conseil d'État a indiqué les aléas
autour de autour de cette loi mais ce
qui est important c'est que la loi de
programmation militaire elle réaffirme
un projet d'armée complet et notamment
l'introduction de capacités dans de
nouveaux champs de conflictualité ce qui
s'ajoutent j'ai cité la lutte dans le
cyberespace la lutte dans le domaine de
l'information et de l'influence et on
voit de nouveaux domaines comme
évidemment autour des drones et de
l'hyper vélocité
évidemment du coup vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président elle a aussi
traduit des ajustements capacitaires
pour être capable de prendre en compte
les réorientations de priorité dans le
domaine du terrestre on l'a vu notamment
dans le cas du problème scorpion qui
même si la cible évidemment n'est pas
modifiée certains livraisons seront
étalées au-delà de 2030 il faudra qu'on
regarde programme par programme les
conséquences que cela veut dire
notamment en termes de capacité
l'industrie s'est organisée pour pour
tenir ses engagements avait investi pour
pour augmenter ses cadences on parle de
jusqu'à 450 véhicules par an par exemple
chaîne externe et il faudra regarder ce
que cela veut dire en terme de capacité
industrielle ou même de de sur le tissu
industriel le modèle de l'industrie
défense est mes collègues le
confirmeront et il est particulier
évidemment par rapport à une industrie
classique le besoin de l'export j'y
reviendrai qui est indispensable pour
pour le modèle
l'impérativité l'impératif d'efficacité
opérationnelle dans ce domaine plus que
dans tout autre industriel le besoin
d'innovation d'innovation incrémentale
on va y revenir des volumes forcément
plus réduits que dans l'industrie de
grande quantité et des cycles de
développement même s'il faut les réduire
qui sont fatalement longs par rapport
au cycle de l'analyse besoin tous ces
caractéristiques nécessitent une
visibilité des commandes et d'éviter le
Stop and Go qui est forcément
préjudiciable aux industriels si on veut
être capable de produire plus vite et
plus selon la logique de l'économie de
guerre
alors ce que l'on note avec avec intérêt
dans la loi de programmation militaire
c'est aussi la volonté d'accroître le
niveau d'activité le niveau de
disponibilité des forces avec une
augmentation du MCO du maintien en
conditions opérationnelles
donc on nous on a noté une augmentation
importante de plusieurs dizaines de %
près de 40% sur la la part du budget qui
est dédié à l'entretien des probable de
matériels et évidemment la disponibilité
pour la cohérence vous parliez et
extrêmement importante on note aussi un
effort particulier autour des munitions
je parlais du besoin spécifique dans le
terrestre de consommation de destruction
d'attrition avec un effort particulier
sur les munitions évidemment dans un
contexte de reconfiguration de
l'industrie des munitions en Europe et
avec quelques impulsions récentes
on salue le l'ASAP à l'acte il supporte
un munition production cette initiative
européenne elle répond aux besoins des
états
on remarque d'ailleurs qu'il est assez
vite ce qui veut dire que le rythme
européen s'est mis au rythme de défense
et au rythme militaire c'est pas c'est
pas toujours et donc c'est saluer
attention que une partie du budget est
prise sur le budget du fait c'est à dire
sur des budget traditionnellement dédié
à l'innovation à la recherche de
développement il faut que ce soit
exceptionnel je vais revenir sur les
besoins sur les besoins de l'innovation
évidemment la France est en position sur
la sur le mission de leadership elle
doit garder sa leadership être vigilante
sur la pérennité du modèle industriel
sur les munitions et notamment les
goulets d'étranglement avec quelques
fournisseurs uniques notamment les les
éléments de poudre
alors dans la loi de programmation
militaire il y a une face importante qui
est accordée à la constitution de stocks
et notamment l'article 24 qui demande
une priorisation nationale sur les
commandes d'export sur le stock et une
imposition administrative sur les stocks
on comprend parfaitement le besoin de
cet article en revanche il est
indispensable qui est une vraie
concertation état industrie
administration et les industrielles
concernés pour travailler sur le volume
les temps stockage nécessaires et que ce
soit soutenable industriellement
opérationnellement et bien sûr
financièrement donc il faut vraiment
continuer ce travail en commun état
industrie avant de d'accélérer toutes
les décisions de la matière même si on
comprend le besoin de cet article donc
ça c'était mon premier sujet sur la
visibilité
le deuxième sur l'innovation et la
recherche et le développement une loi de
programmation militaire on l'a dit et
elle est là pour largement au-delà de
décennie elle doit aussi anticiper les
les sauts technologiques et les besoins
capacitaires importants dans le domaine
terrestre j'en cite quelques-uns le
combat collaboratif et au-delà de ce que
fait scorpion la capacité
d'interconnecter au débit capteur
réflecteurs véhicules de tout type et
drone
le futur de la frappe dans la profondeur
le tournant de la robotique terrestre on
comprend très bien que la robotique
terrestre est décalée dans le temps par
rapport au drone aérien marin et
sous-marin on comprend parfaitement
pourquoi mais ils seront malgré tout une
révolution sur le théâtre d'opération
tous les travaux de novation autour du
Sud la succession du Charles Leclerc et
bien sûr les enjeux de la transition
énergétique donc il faut continuer à
investir sur la R&D sinon on prend le
risque d'être déclassé
d'une façon générale et c'est ma
transition vers le troisième point
dans les termes capacitaires d'une loi
de programmation il faut travailler sur
la masse et le nombre suffisant la
maintenance il soit saute table on l'a
dit l'efficacité mais aussi la nécessité
la nécessité d'export et d'exportabilité
et donc j'en viens à mon troisième sujet
l'export l'export c'est plus de 40% pour
l'industrie terrestre en 2021 l'export
est indispensable au format que le
ministre appelé athlétique et souverain
de notre BITD
souvent ne peut pas être assuré
seulement avec les commandes nationales
donc on a une concurrence à
l'exportation avec des BITD concurrentes
qui profitent d'un soutien étatique fort
je pense à la Turquie dans présence dans
plusieurs pays européens je pense à la
Corée du Sud qui a marché intérieur de
char phénoménal et qui a des centaines
de pièces d'artillerie aujourd'hui en
projet en Europe je pense aux Israéliens
et naturellement aux Américains et
notamment sur sur le high mars donc
l'export c'est une bataille permanente
ce qui est important sur l'export
terrestre c'est de dire d'abord qu'il
n'y a pas de concurrence terre Hermer et
il y a pas de concurrence entre
industrielle dans le domaine dans le
domaine terrestre il y a peu de très
grands projets c'est plutôt une
multitude de petits projets il y a
beaucoup de succès des uns qui préparent
les succès des autres on regarde en
Grèce entre le Rafale et les frégates en
Croatie entre le Rafale et le crotale et
d'une façon générale de toute façon les
programmes terrestres sont de plus
petites tailles mais mais très nombreux
mais il faut donc agir en équipe de
France et dans certains pays je pense
par exemple le César en Lituanie c'est
un pays qui n'a pas d'armée de l'air
c'est un pays dans la façade maritime
est réduite le soutien terrestre de la
France à la Lituanie et par exemple
indispensable donc je conclus avec mes
trois points principaux la visibilité
c'est nécessaire pour la montée en
puissance et rappelons-nous que la
Défense Terrestre c'est 75% de PME
la recherche est développement et
l'innovation pour préparer l'avenir être
leader dans les capacités clés qu'on
voit évoluer et puis l'export et les
coopérations c'est un revenu d'influence
mais aussi la condition de pérennité de
notre modèle je vous remercie vraiment
de votre attention merci président
après peut-être que du reste vous nous
parlerez aussi des problèmes de
financement alors c'est pas exact c'est
pas effectivement dans le cadre de la
LPM enfin c'est un problème récurrent
qui revient et notamment à texto-mani
etc enfin puisqu'on vous a sous la main
on profitera de pour avoir en direct
votre avis sur ce sujet quand même assez
inquiétant alors en l'absence du
président du GIFAS nous allons entrer en
mer avec Pierre Eric Pommelet président
de naval Group est président du Gicam
voilà donc merci président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs très
heureux d'être avec vous ce matin et
comme vous l'avez dit Président nous
allons à parier pour quelques minutes de
présentation générale de du gitan et de
la déclinaison navale de cette
programmation militaire peut-être juste
le gicant rappelé ce que c'est hautement
des industries des constructions alors
c'était arme naval mais je crois que le
mot arme naval un peu disparu mais enfin
on va dire c'est la construction navale
qui regroupe de 60 adhérents 80% de
l'activité du secteur à peu près 13
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et 51
000 emplois sur notre territoire voilà
c'est une activité maillée alors elle
est pas uniquement littorale même si
évidemment elle a un impact extrêmement
important dans les grands ports de notre
pays et à l'international mais comme
d'ailleurs les autres groupements de
défense c'est une activité qui est
extraordinairement diversifiée et
disperser répartie dans le territoire je
crois d'ailleurs c'est c'est ce qui nous
caractérise Guillaume foril ne
rappellera pour le GIFAS quand il
arrivera et quand on est ensemble on
s'appelle le sidaf d'ailleurs le Conseil
des industries de défense on réalise à
quel point notre industrie est
souveraine dans sa répartition
géographique je crois qu'il y a pas un
territoire qui n'est pas immergé par
l'industrie de défense ce sont 200 000
emplois des emplois non délocalisables
et des emplois qui contribuent à la
souveraineté et la puissance de notre
pays
alors si
nous nous regardons la LPM notre
programmation militaire le premier
message qui nous vient c'est c'est la
conscience de l'effort qui est réalisé
413 milliards c'est un enfant
considérable vous l'avez rappelé
président en augmentation par rapport
aux lois de programmation précédente et
je pense que pour une industrie de
défense une industrie souveraine c'est
un effort qui nous engage nous sommes
parfaitement conscients de ce que la
nation va porter dans son outil de
défense et quelque part le
l'engagement que nous avons de servir
notre pays de servir nos armées et donc
de livrer l'ensemble des équipements qui
nous seront commandés
le deuxième message je crois que Marc
Damon l'a largement répété c'est la
visibilité et c'est vrai qu'une loi de
programmation militaire donne une
visibilité et la visibilité est
essentielle dans une industrie de temps
long rappelle souvent nous sommes
nous sommes une industrie de temps long
on va pas le regarder le rappeler sur
l'âge de nos entreprises en particulier
celles que j'ai la chance de diriger
mais juste donner l'exemple des
sous-marins nucléaires lanceurs d'engins
le programme troisième génération qui
est confirmé par ces plateformation
militaires au titre de la de la
dissuasion dissuasion d'ailleurs qui est
un des éléments extrêmement importants
sécurisé dans cette loi en tout cas qui
est proposé dans cette loi le programme
essaye le 3G a démarré depuis
déjà une ou deux décennies en étudemment
et en prédéveloppement il est en
développement laboration militaire
confirmera la poursuite du développement
le lancement du premier navire qui sera
en service en 2035 le quatrième bâton en
2050 ils seront en service jusqu'en 2090
j'ai dit souvent le grand-père le
grand-père du commandant du dernier
bâtiment estné le 3G vient juste de
naître sans doute ou et tout jeune en
tout cas le père n'est pas né ça c'est
sûr voilà donc industrie de temps long
et industrie de visibilité et cette loi
de programmation militaire à la suite
des précédentes confirment cette
visibilité c'est extrêmement important
dans le domaine naval et pour la Marine
nationale la loi de programmation
militaire confirme le renouvellement
finalement quasi complet de notre flotte
alors il a commencé dans les lois
précédentes avec les programmes frame le
lancement de la prime FDI évidemment les
sous-marins Barracuda dont le dont la
production se déroulera tout au long de
cette décennie le deuxième sous-marin
Barracuda le Ducret est en mer en ce
moment
quelque part comme on dit il fait ses
essais à la mer il sera livré la marine
cet été et le dernier Barracuda sortira
avant la fin de la décennie ce qui est
un renouvellement complet de la flotte
de sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque
renouvellement des sous-marins lanceurs
d'engins je l'ai dit renouvellement de
la flotte de la du groupe aéronavale
avec la confirmation du calendrier du
porte-avion je répondrai tout de suite
au sujet du financement président
puisque moi est posé la question
juste après ce propos liminaire mais
aussi renouvellement des frégates on
poursuites du renouvellement avec les
frégates de défense et d'intervention
alors c'est sûr dans un calendrier qui
est pas forcément celui qui avait été
imaginé au départ mais là qui lie
finalement nos programmes nationaux et
l'exportation j'en dirai de mots juste
après
mais aussi renouvellement des
patrouilleurs métropolitains
remplacement des aviso escorters avec un
programme qui est extrêmement important
pour les plus petits chantiers que naval
group ou chantier de l'Atlantique on
parle ici de pirius au carénam CMN avec
donc c'est patrouilleur métropolitain
renouvellement de la composante de
guerre des mines avec la rejoindre très
proche par la France du programme
belgo-néerlandais pour poursuivre
l'aventure des chasseurs de mine
tripartite je sais que c'est un
programme qui vous est cher président
notamment sur l'un d'entre eux mais
aussi qui amène et qui amènera cette
composante de guerre des mines
l'utilisation de drones et de système de
drone et de systèmes automatiques
puisque c'est bien l'objectif d'un tel
programme renouvellement des bâtiments
ravitailleurs de peut-être arrêter la
liste mais c'est vrai que quand on
regarde les 10 ans qui viennent en
particulier porté par cela de
programmation militaire c'est un
renouvellement complet de la flotte
française qui est en train d'être
réalisée et qui est confirmé donc dans
cette dans cette visibilité
le sujet de la recherche et de
développement de l'innovation qui a été
évoquée par Marc Darmon est extrêmement
important à la fois dans des roadmates
incrémentales la loi de programmation
militaire avec les programmes evols et
Sénat et evolent frégate crante le fait
que
et l'affirmation du fait que il est
extrêmement difficile d'anticiper un
instant donné qu'elle sera le monde ne
serait-ce que dans quelques années et
donc sur ces programmes de temps long il
vaut mieux les concevoir en standard et
faire évoluer les standards en fonction
du besoin militaire de l'environnement
de la capacité
éventuellement ennemie que nous devons
combattre mais aussi de la capacité
industrielle et bien sûr des capacités
de financement donc la notion
d'incrémentale est importante à l'écran
t elle est identifiée dans cette LPM il
sera important de sur ces programmes-là
et voler Wolf frégate de regarder
comment il se concrétise
justement sur les évolutions à venir sur
la recherche et le développement
et en particulier sur le programme 144
la confirmation de des budgets et des
crédits d'étudemment qui prépare
l'avenir dans le domaine naval comme
dans les autres alors dans le domaine
aval il y a un segment qui nous est cher
qui est celui des drones et des systèmes
de drones
identifiés en tant que tel avec je l'ai
dit les problèmes de guerre des mines
mais nous l'espérons aussi des problèmes
de drone plus ambitieux capacitaires
drone océaniques dans le bâtiment de
surface qui seront des composantes
extrêmement importantes demain sur le
sujet de la coopération et de
l'exportation et je terminerai le propos
liminaire là dessus deux programmes sont
importants et identifiés dans la
programmation militaire j'ai parlé du
problème de guerre des mines où la
France rejoindra la Belgique et les
Pays-Bas programme de coopération à
venir et le la modernisation des
frégates horizons en en coopération avec
l'Italie qui est aussi un programme à
venir et porté par cette loi
programmation
voilà donc visibilité renouvellement des
flottes et calendrier financement alors
c'est vrai que sur le calendrier là nos
chantiers ont une activité marque
d'amour l'a rappelé c'est pareil dans le
naval qui est une complémentarité entre
la France et l'Internationale et c'est
vrai que c'est difficile de planifier
d'avance qu'elles vont être exactement
les programmes français internationaux
qui chargeront notre chantier je peux
juste rappeler ce qui s'est passé dans
la programmation militaire précédente
les frégats de défense et d'intervention
étaient décalés étaient plus loin que ce
que le chantier pouvait construire
d'ailleurs le chantier naval de Lorient
cette organisé exemple d'économie de
guerre pour fabriquer deux frégates
Corvette par an
était plus loin dans la programmation
militaire dans les années 2019-2020 on a
identifié une problématique de charge
industrielle discussion avec le
ministère des armées décisions de la
ministre des armées de l'époque
d'avancer finalement les frégates FDI 2
et 3 françaises pour soutenir la charge
industrielle de l'Orient mais aussi de
lancer ensemble parce que l'exportation
c'est une équipe de France de lancer
ensemble des campagnes à l'exportation
et en particulier en Grèce qui était
intéressé par les frégates FDI et le
fait d'avoir avancé par rapport à ce
qu'est l'information militaire nous a
permis de sécuriser un calendrier dit de
cycles courts qui intéressait les Grecs
qui ont finalement signé un contrat
avec un accord de la France pour prendre
les frégates 2 et 3 qui avait été avancé
pour les livres à la Grèce et les
frégates sont finalement revenus dans le
calendrier initial de la LPM c'est pour
ça que c'est calendrier de Fregate
doivent être vu à l'aune des campagnes
internationales et d'exportation c'est
ce qui va nous occuper et je me étant
devant vous président et devant
et devant la représentation nationale de
vous remercier pour tout ce que vous
faites au titre de la diplomatie
parlementaire parce que beaucoup de nos
pays clients ou potentiels clients
apprécient les contacts directs avec les
parlementaires voilà donc ça c'est un
travail de l'équipe de France dont vous
faites partie et qui à la fin donnera la
charge industrielle loi de programmation
militaire et ses séquences de programme
capacité de gagner à l'exportation alors
juste je termine ainsi mon propos
liminaire mais répondre à une question
que vous avez posée sur le financement
en particulier le financement du
porte-avion qui est un sujet qui a été
évoqué et qui finalement amène la
discussion des calendriers des
programmes et des flux financiers les
deux sont liés bien évidemment
et je pense que ce qui a été annoncé et
ce qui est proposé dans la loi de
programmation militaire c'est déjà de
tenir le calendrier du porte-avion
nouvelle génération et en particulier le
calendrier de sa chaufferie nucléaire
puisque là aussi dans ces programmes de
temps long parfois il est étonnant de
voir à quel point la chaufferie
nucléaire ou l'élément nucléaire peut
paraître en amont par rapport au cycle
le porte-avion est prévu d'être mis en
service en 2038 mais la chaufferie
nucléaire ne peut pas attendre et les
premiers éléments ont déjà été fondus
chez Framatome et les investissements
sont réalisés aux gens qui sont notre
site d'adrett pour être capable d'usiner
les éléments de chaufferie en 2023 donc
un certain temps avant et c'est pour ça
que et sur le sous-marin nucléaire
troisième génération dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure nous
usinons en ce moment un drets les
premiers éléments de cuve de la
chaufferie et de brides de la chaufferie
nucléaire du bateau qui sera servi en
et
la première tôle sera usinée à Cherbourg
à la fin de l'année voilà donc dans ces
programmes de temps long le calendrier
et le maintien du calendrier est
extrêmement important si on veut le
vider et ce qui a été décidé c'est de
maintenir ce calendrier par l'avant
projet détaillé projet dans la
programmation militaire mais à démarrage
immédiat et ensuite des 2024 2025 les
éléments chauffent nucléaire et
développement de lancement et
réalisations en 2025 2026 il a été
demandé à l'industrie si nous étions
d'accord pour que les flux de paiement
fassent partie de la négociation
d'ensemble et la réponse a été oui je
dirais ça fait partie d'une manière
générale des négociations que nous avons
entre le calendrier et la nécessité de
le maintenir les paiements
correspondants et les flux et les
crédits de paiement associés mais c'est
surtout à l'horizon 2025 2026 au moment
de la dansement de développement et
réalisation que le flux importants
seront engagés et que cette question du
financement sera posée voilà donc elle
est un peu préliminaire aujourd'hui elle
se posera dans le flux de développement
du programme en tout cas je peux vous
dire que sur l'avant projet détaillé
c'est un contrat dont nous terminons
avons terminé la négociation avec le
mystère des armées ce sujet de
financement a fait partie de la
négociation et a été résolu voilà ce que
je pouvais dire sur le sujet du
financement du porte-avion
alors j'ai pas tenu suffisamment je
crois Guillaume Faury avait une estimée
totalement à rival à 9h31 il est 9h30
mais on peut déjà peut-être commencer à
répondre à quelques questions avant que
avant que
les rapporteurs vont s'exprimer sur
l'ensemble mais bon
si vous voulez en attendant l'arrivée de
mon Président je peux peut-être décrire
ce qu'elles j'y fasse aujourd'hui
ça représente la quasi-totalité de
l'industrie automatique et spatiale
française aussi bien défense que civile
c'est 444
entreprise
dont depuis l'été dernier une
quarantaine de start-up en 2022 c'est
62,7 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires France
des emplois répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire national bien sûr davantage
en Île-de-France en
Occitanie en nouvelle-aquitaine et en
région sud que dans d'autres régions
mais malgré tout on est on est très
ancrés sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est également 195000 emplois directs
avec plus de 80% des produits exportés
et si on fait un focus sur la défense
alors les entreprises du Gifa réalisent
un chiffre d'affaires de 19,2 milliards
d'euros dans la défense avec plus de
60000 personnes dédiées là aussi comme
mes documents l'ont dit des emplois très
qualifiés ancré sur le territoire donc
non délocalisables
avec
une commande défense de
40 milliards d'euros et dans 70% à
l'export
et donc
je vais laisser maintenant Guillaume on
organise le salon du Bourget bien sûr à
compter du 19 juin vous êtes bien
évidemment les bienvenus ça sera un
plaisir de vous accueillir et puis le
salon du Bourget c'est le plus grand
salon érotique au monde maintenant mon
président est arrivé je vais décrire
simplement ce que tu avais dit
je suis heureux d'être arrivé alors
merci
de bien vouloir m'accueillir aujourd'hui
j'ai fait mieux que j'ai pu pour être
présent à 9h30 comme je m'étais engagé
quand je vois tous les obstacles qu'on a
dans et autour de Paris
je me dis parfois on n'a pas besoin
d'ennemis pour perdre la guerre bon mais
bon je suis arrivé
monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs
permettez-moi de remercier la commission
de la défense des forces armées des
Affaires étrangères du Sénat pour
permettre à travers la voie du gif face
à la BITD de s'exprimer devant vous à la
veille d'un débat parlementaire
important sur la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire 2024 2030 comme
vous le savez l'industrie en éthique et
spatiale française
on va dire européenne est aujourd'hui
face à des défis majeurs dans le civil
et dans le minuteur par ailleurs le
contexte de guerre en Europe mais
d'économie de guerre change la donne
imposant à nouveau l'aptitude au combat
de haute intensité ce qui engendre
nécessairement des conséquences
importantes pour l'outil industriel
s'agissant de la LPM ce budget de 413
milliards d'euros représentent
naturellement un effort très conséquent
dans un contexte budgétaire difficile
l'industrie on a pleinement conscience
et j'allais dire comme à son habitude va
s'attacher à en optimiser l'usage et
l'utilisation
une loi de programmation est toujours un
cadre très attendue car il donne de la
perspective à l'industrie en lui
permettant d'adapter son outil de
production ses compétences ces
ressources les adaptées aux objectifs
fixés et également d'orienter la
recherche et la technologie
j'insiste sur un point nous sommes une
industrie de haute technologie de
d'objets et de systèmes sophistiqués
souvent gros et très complexe
qui est une industrie de long terme donc
elle a absolument besoin de la
visibilité de visibilité et de la
visibilité qu'une loi de programmation
permet d'obtenir
cette loi de programmation dans le
budget augmente de manière significative
s'inscrit dans la continuité de la loi
actuelle dite exécutée à l'euro près ce
qui a permis de redonner la dynamique
attendue aussi bien par les forces que
par le monde industriel et dans ce
dernier à se projeter avec des plans de
charges plus prévisibles
cette nouvelle LPM consacre des moyens
significatifs significatifs excusez-moi
à des domaines capacitaires
qui étaient jugés non ou moins
prioritaire dans les précédentes
programmation et dont les chaînes de
production avaient pu être organisées et
maintenu à travers un certain nombre
d'outils dont en particulier
l'exportation
cette nouvelle loi de programmation
prend en compte la nécessité d'investir
pour faire face à de nouveaux enjeux en
particulier dans des nouveaux champs de
conflictualité
l'espace le cyber évidemment les fonds
sous-marins et quelques autres à cela
s'ajoutent les forts importants
consacrés au maintien de la posture
permanente de dissuasion
identifier réaffirmer comme la priorité
des priorités conformément au dernier
discours du président à Mont-de-Marsan
les forts réalisés permettra d'assurer
le maintien de compétences essentielles
dans ces domaines elle voit également le
lancement des travaux relatifs au
lancement du successeur du Charles de
Gaulle
le nouveau contexte géopolitique en
premier lieu conséquence du conflit
Russo ukrainien
apporte un certain nombre de changements
importants ayant indispensable un
investissement spécifique significatif
en particulier pour le renforcement des
stocks de munitions
l'urgence de la situation change
cette nouvelle loi possède donc des
facto un champ d'application beaucoup
plus vaste et beaucoup plus large que la
précédente LPM ainsi qu'un niveau de
complexité vraiment spécifique et dans
un contexte budgétaire que nous savons
tous très contraints devant en plus
intégrer l'inflation provisionner je
crois à hauteur de 30 milliards d'euros
le modèle d'armée 2030 est conforté mais
devrait connaître un décalage dans
l'aboutissement de certaines de ses
dimensions par rapport à l'objectif
initial du fait des charges nouvelles de
l'extension du spectre et des nouvelles
contraintes dont je viens de parler
l'industrie devra s'adapter en
conséquence
ce projet de loi définit un cadre
général qui devrait décliné dans le
détail comme pour chaque nouvelle loi
programme par programme
industriel par industriel entreprises
par entreprise
des compromis devront être trouvés quant
aux outils de production
conciliant certains décalages de cible
et les contraintes industrielles pour
assurer la viabilité des outils
industriels et en définissant les
conditions d'une remontée en cadence
appropriée en cas de crise approprié au
sens de sa vitesse et de son ampleur
plus qualitativement ce travail
permettra de s'assurer de l'absence de
perte de compétences dans les domaines
clés que ce soit dans le domaine
essentiel des bureaux d'études des
compétences technologiques pour
préserver leur niveau de technologie ou
dans ceux de la réalisation de la
production de la fabrication et aussi
évidemment du maintien en compétences en
conditions opérationnelle du MCO
sur les bureaux d'études au-delà des
nouveaux programmes des évolutions de
standards des équipements actuels sont
également essentiels au-delà de ces
enjeux programmatiques une lecture
superficielle du projet de texte de loi
pourrait laisser penser que la dimension
européenne serait moins un axe majeur de
la politique de défense je crois qu'un
examen plus attentif montre que les
arbitrages rendus ne perturbent pas la
conduite des programmes majeurs qui ont
été qui existaient ou qui ont été
initiés par la loi en cours que ce soit
dans le domaine absolument crucial je
dirais presque même existentielle du FK
ainsi que dans le domaine du drone mal
par exemple
je me permets une aparté sur le la
dimension européenne la dimension de
coopération entre pays européens je
pense que cette approche de coopération
demeure absolument essentielle car elle
apporte dans les systèmes où les
investissements sont absolument
considérables à des échelles très
importantes et où les séries sont
petites la masse critique qui est
absolument indispensable à leur maîtrise
technologique et économique et à la
préservation ou à la construction dans
certains cas des critères de
souveraineté que ce soit la souveraineté
européenne ou nationale ou la
souveraineté à plusieurs pays dans un
marché qui est très fortement
concurrencé et en particulier
noyé submerger ensevelie par l'offre
américaine qui elle est extrêmement
structurée et à l'échelle dont je
parlais précédemment
le dialogue doit être poursuivi avec la
DGA au sujet de l'utilisation du fait du
Fonds européen de défense dans le
développement des capacités
technologiques compte tenu des
difficultés que nous rencontrons parfois
souvent à comprendre les modalités
d'intégration des projets que nous
déposons alors que la couverture de nos
coûts demeure de notre point de vue très
imparfaite malgré nos alertes répétées
dans ce domaine
ce projet de LPM
aborde plusieurs sujets identifiés dans
le cadre de la préparation à l'économie
de guerre prise de risque dans
l'innovation constitution de stocks de
matières premières que l'État pourrait
être imposé aux industriels et la mise
en place d'un MCO en rapport avec le
niveau d'activité des forces attendues
le Gifa estime qu'il est important de
poursuivre le dialogue des Géa est à
major des armées industries afin
d'élaborer de manière concertée une
stratégie sur ces sujets majeurs
à titre d'exemple la prise de risque
dans l'innovation sujet que l'industrie
met en avant aussi depuis plusieurs
années ce sujet est abordé sans que les
modalités de mise en oeuvre ne soient
précisées compte tenu des enjeux à venir
et des pantacités qu'offrent les
ruptures technologiques en cours une
réflexion partagée serait de nature à
affirmer le positionnement de la France
sur des sujets essentiels par exemple
l'intelligence artificielle qui seront
qui sera en ce qui concerne la science
artificielle indispensable pour mener et
gagner la guerre de demain
les groupes de travail éteint industrie
constitués pour les travaux sur
l'économie de guerre stocke et
approvisionnement ou encore MCO doivent
être pleinement sollicités pour
alimenter les travaux d'implémentation
de la LPM
cette coordination est indispensable
pour définir des mesures des façons de
travailler qui fonctionneront le jour où
on les solliciteront
le projet de LPM comporte un projet un
volet normatif important dont trois
articles concernent très directement
l'industrie les 23 24 25 l'article 23
modernise et adapte le régime des
réquisitions du Code de la défense
l'article 24 organise la possibilité de
constituer des stocks stratégiques
matières ou composants pour les armées
ainsi que la priorisation de la
livraison de biens et services au
bénéfice des armées et l'article 25 fait
évoluer le régime des enquêtes de coups
dans les marchés publics
partie 23 n'appelle pas de commentaires
particuliers de ma part il en va
autrement des articles 24 et 25
l'article 24 dans sa rédaction actuelle
et porteur de nombreux incertitudes pour
l'industrie tant pour la partie sur les
stocks que sur la priorisation selon
leurs conditions de mise en oeuvre les
obligations auxquelles les industriels
devraient faire face pourraient avoir un
impact significatif tant en termes de
coût mais aussi d'image et de réputation
auprès des clients étrangers
et donc des faits négatifs parmi les
nombreuses questions identifiées quels
sont les modalités de constitution des
stocks tant de constitution volume
nature quels sont les produits concernés
quels seront les coûts de la
constitution des stocks y compris
l'aspect logistique
quelle sera la durée d'immobilisation
d'un stock
qu'en est-il des couvertures des
conséquences indirectes de la
réorientation d'une commande prévue pour
un client export contenu de cette
obligation de stockage et puis je l'ai
dit l'impact réputationnel et les
dommages qui pourraient en résulter il
est nécessaire ce sont des questions
auxquelles il faut rapporter les
réponses il nécessaire que le groupe de
travail était industriste toi qui
approvisionnement soit saisi ce qu'il y
en a connaissance n'a pas été le cas
jusqu'à présent
et établisse en commun les voix pour
arriver à mécanisme répondant aux
besoins de l'État et de l'industrie
l'article 25 propose de créer un nouvel
article
l2196-7 du code de la commande publique
permettant d'établir par décret d'une
part la forme selon laquelle les
éléments techniques et comptables de
l'estimation du coût de revient doivent
être présentés à l'administration si
celle-ci en fait la demande et d'autre
part la nature des charges comprise dans
la détermination du coût de revient et
les modalités de leur comptabilisation
avec ce nouvel article le ministère des
armées aura donc la possibilité de
définir de façon impérative la nature
d'un coup éligible or les industriels
n'ont pas tous la même organisation
industrielle loin de là ni la même
structure de coût encore moins une
méthode unique de définition des coûts
ne peut donc être appliqué sous peine
d'affecter durablement le fonctionnement
des entreprises concernées par ailleurs
la nature conflictuelle des relations
entre
les différentes parties sur les ECV
depuis de nombreuses années illustre la
divergence d'approches sur ce dossier et
sur certains points très particuliers et
importants pour nous l'analyse de ces
deux articles et leurs effets potentiels
pour les industriels rend indispensables
de notre point de vue l'association de
l'industrie à la rédaction des décrets
d'application afin de faire préciser les
nombreux points encore flou et éviter
les désaccords pour au contraire établir
un dispositif répondant aux besoins et
contraintes de l'ensemble des parties
les besoins et contraintes des armées et
nous les comprenons mais aussi celles
des industriels
le monde industriel est convaincu de la
nécessité de travailler différemment
mais conjointement pour assurer un
écosystème de défense robuste et pérenne
cela passe par davantage de
contraception entre une concertation
entre partenaires l'économie de guerre
pourrait en donner l'occasion sous
réserve que les méthodes de travail
entre la DGA les forces et l'industrie
évoluent cette dynamique que les
industriels appellent également de leurs
vœux permettrait entre autres l'agit-il
et nécessaire à la construction des
capacités de défense intégrant les
capacités d'innovation l'adaptation des
normes et des règlements au juste besoin
le soutien à l'export conditionnant la
pérennité du modèle industriel français
en particulier sur les systèmes nous
avons une petite échelle et où on voit
les outils industriels avoir des hauts
et des bas qui sont très difficiles à
gérer
dynamique qui permettrait dans le but de
faire fructifier l'impulsion donnée par
le Président de la République et
d'optimiser l'emploi des budgets de
défense j'approche de la fin de mon
intervention dans un monde caractérisé
par l'instabilité géopolitique la
défense française a besoin d'une
stratégie capacitaire ambitieuse
celle-ci ne peut être construite que
collectivement par une concertation
étroite entre les parties étatiques et
industrielles
dans un monde complexe avec des
objectifs partagés et la volonté
d'innover dans les méthodes de travail
pour plus d'efficacité de réactivité
pour lesquelles les améliorations sont
indispensables pour nos armées et cela
avec une juste maîtrise des coûts merci
de votre attention
merci président
alors si vous le voulez bien on va
entendre les observations de nos
différents rapporteurs et chacun d'entre
vous pourra
programme par programme répondre je
demande à chacun contenu de l'ordre du
jour à ses denses
limitées sont temps d'intervention et
donc on va commencer par le 178
préparation emplois des forces Olivier
sigoletti
merci monsieur le Président
depuis maintenant d'un peu plus de 15
mois la guerre en Ukraine a changé la
donne remettant au cœur des priorités
les services de soutien et vous l'avez
évoqué chacun à votre tour dans vos
compétences respectives avec bien sûr
les stocks de munitions et la
préparation opérationnelle la guerre en
Ukraine a imposé une certaine forme de
vérité des prix sur ce qui coûte
réellement la guerre on ne pourra plus
désormais rogner comme cela a été fait y
compris dans la LPM actuelle
sur
ce qui a été fait donc sur le MCO sur
l'entraînement sur les stocks et sur les
services de soutien dans ces conditions
malgré les efforts annoncés nous sommes
au sein de la commission soucieux des
perspectives de l'EPN de la préparation
opérationnelle liée à la disponibilité
technique
nous avons cru comprendre il y a
quelques jours que la DGA pourrait être
en charge de l'amélioration des contrats
verticalisés qui se sont généralisés
dans tous les domaines de l'EPM est-ce
que vous avez déjà sur ce sujet mais sur
les présidents quelques objectifs
quelques indicateurs de performance qui
vous ont été précisés est-ce que vous
disposez de la visibilité sur les moyens
prévus pour le PN tout au long de la
prochaine période de programmation ce
qui nous semble indispensable pour que
vous puissiez mettre en œuvre les outils
industriels les plus adaptés la
prochaine LPM recherche un optimum
économique arbitrant entre deux
variables majeures l'activité et la
disponibilité technique fournie à partir
de pièces de rechange et de réponses
techniques transmises par les
industriels titulaires des contrats
verticalisés est-ce que le raisonnement
visant à réduire une supposée sur
disponibilité pour financer plus
d'heures d'activités vous paraît
rationnels économiquement et
techniquement pour nous il nous semble
conduire à une sur usure des équipements
et à l'érosion plus rapide du capital
technique des armées avez-vous alerté le
ministère sur ces points et quels sont
les conséquences de cet arbitrage
éventuel et comment est-ce que la sur
usure pourrait-elle prise être prise en
compte dans vos nouveaux contrats
verticalisés merci
merci Olivier donc maintenant Michel
gréaume rapporteur de 78 merci monsieur
le président
Messieurs les Présidents je souhaite
vous interroger sur les conséquences
pour vous de certains choix qui
pourraient passer relativement inaperçu
et qui me semble devoir impacter
largement vos activités
s'agissant des contrats opérationnels
les moyens détaillés dans les postures
de réactivité comme dans le complément
en cas d'engagement majeur sont prévus
par la précédente LPM nous nous
attendions plutôt à ce que la
perspective d'un engagement majeur
conduise à les augmenter ou au moins à
les stabilité peut-être partager vous
cette analyse et donc une certaine
déception peut-être comment la réduction
de ces formats vous impactera-t-elle les
besoins de services de soutien qui
bénéficieront de 4 milliards
supplémentaires en 7 ans sont immenses
êtes-vous bien mobilisés sur les besoins
de renouvellement des équipements du
service de l'énergie opérationnelle du
service du commissariat des armées et du
service de santé des armées et à quel
horizon merci
messieurs si vous voulez bien répondre
si vous en avez si vous en ressentez le
besoin
c'est vrai que beaucoup de questions
extrêmement précises peut-être pas
forcément répondre à tout en tout cas
mais
sur le sujet de la du soutien et
notamment des contrats verticalisés je
vais répondre pour le domaine naval
cette c'est un mouvement qui a pris le
service de soutien de la flotte et qui
amène je pense aujourd'hui des résultats
sur la disponibilité de nos flottes et
la disponibilité qu'il s'agisse de
flotte les évidemment à la dissuasion ou
ou aux flottes de surface alors il y a
quelque chose d'extrêmement important et
enfin j'espère que cette LPM permettra
de progresser qui est toute
l'architecture digitale le numérique
autour du soutien et du service parce
que
afin d'assurer une pleine disponibilité
de tout évidence nous pourrons disposer
dans le cadre de contrat alors on va
dire verticalisé en tout cas qui ont une
unité
de vision entre le client l'opérationnel
et les industriels de disposer de
structures numériques et de structures
de données qui vont permettre d'avoir
une efficacité dans la maintenance
préventive l'utilisation d'algorithmie
une intelligence artificielle etc info
il faut pas voir le contrat uniquement
comme une structure contractuelle mais
aussi la capacité de partager des
données différemment et donc ça c'est
pour moi un des sujets forts je crois
que ça a commencé dans l'aéronautique
voilà le naval s'y met et c'est vraiment
porteur d'efficacité de disponibilité on
parliez d'érosion des matériels je pense
que à partir du moment on est capable
d'échanger de traiter des données nous
aurons en tout cas l'industrie et ses
clients militaires des géants services
de soutien auront une bien meilleure
capacité à anticiper cette fameuse
érosion et donc à travailler à la fois
sur les procédures de soutien mais aussi
sur le design des équipements pour les
plus robustes à certains concepts voilà
donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que le
l'accroissement des moyens dans le
soutien est aussi l'occasion de
progresser dans le domaine du digital et
d'avoir une efficacité d'ensemble je
pense que ça peut être un des sujets
extrêmement importants de cette future
LPM en tout cas dans cette espèce en 18
toutes nos trois trois éléments de
réponse aux questions qui ont été posées
d'abord une réponse très simple sur
l'équilibre entre le soutien le matière
conditionnelle et les nouveaux
équipements évidemment ces sujets par
sujet qu'il faut regarder l'équilibre on
peut tout à fait comprendre que dans une
préparation de combat de haute intensité
on fasse un effort particulier sur la
cohérence de l'ensemble et notamment la
disponibilité et la capacité de
d'efficacité de l'outil et donc
globalement l'augmentation en proportion
du maintien en condition personnelle et
pas surprenante et assez logique je
voudrais dire un mot sur les sujets de
globalisation de vérité en complément de
ce qu'a dit Pierre Éric pommelé dans le
domaine terrestre on a une
verticalisation un peu moins forte qu'on
peut la voir dans le domaine
aéronautique et naval puisque comme je
vous l'ai dit dans l'introduction une
grande partie de nos projets de nos
opérations ne sont pas forcément à
travers des grands programmes de
plateforme mais beaucoup de équipements
de beaucoup de domaines dans le domaine
du soutien dans le domaine de la
logistique du génie de la santé et est
situé etc en revanche ça n'empêche pas
des globalisations un contrat et
notamment des massifications toujours
soutenu effectivement que me disait
pierre et paumé par le numérique le
numérique pour travailler sur le
maintenance prédictive pour
l'optimisation la disponibilités des
pièces pour l'intelligence artificielle
qui aide à mieux détecter les pannes et
donc avec des engagements de
disponibilité de performance de la part
des industriels qui sont
contractualisées pour augmenter le
niveau de disponibilité avec souvent
d'ailleurs les engagements de résultats
plutôt que des listes de réparations ou
de rechange
troisième élément donc sur pas mal les
sujets de soutien de l'homme de
commissariat et d'énergie opérationnelle
comme vous le savez les groupements que
nous représentons tous les trois ne sont
pas seulement là pour parler pour passer
la parole industrielle dans les
auditions comme celle-là elles sont
surtout là pour engager le dialogue état
industrie administration ingénieur sur
ce qui existe sur ce qui est faisable et
notamment à travers le travail de nos
commissions le travail de commission ce
sont des lieux d'échanges dans lequel
pour simplifier les industriels sont
capables de ensemble
échanger sur ce qui est possible et
l'avenir et des opérationnels sur le
besoin et les gestion de priorité nous
avons au J4 établi deux commissions
depuis peu mais extrêmement active une
sur l'énergie opérationnelle justement
au sens large et une sur le soutien de
l'homme et l'équipement du soldat
justement par rapport à aux questions
que vous posez la structuration de la
BTD dans le domaine et surtout les
échanges états industriels dans le
domaine étant extrêmement important
merci Président je me sens
un peu moins capable de répondre à la
deuxième question je dois l'avouer donc
je
suis désolé de pas avoir de choses
vraiment pertinentes à répondre à la
deuxième en ce qui concerne la première
dans le domaine aéronautique et spatial
mais on dit qu'en particulier les
contrats verticalisés ont maintenant une
certaine ancienneté et la performance et
la réussite de certains de ces contrats
à entraîner une approche pour en avoir
plus pour essayer de voir là où on
pouvait les étendre et ce que je vois
c'est effectivement des contrats
verticalisés qui ont été mis en place au
cas par cas et
le niveau de satisfaction aujourd'hui
sur la mise en oeuvre de ces contrats et
très satisfaisant et à donner beaucoup
de bonnes choses donc je pense qu'on est
encore loin d'avoir complètement déployé
ces contrats
quand on quand les armées quand les
forces armées s'équipent de système
complexes sophistiqué pour mener le
combat dans des environnements
soit de haute intensité soit de grandes
complexité ils peuvent avoir soit envie
d'avoir une capacité qu'on va peut
mettre en oeuvre mais qu'on a et qu'on
est prête à utiliser et où la
disponibilité du niveau d'activité est
pas forcément la priorité et c'est le
coût de possession qui va être une
priorité on va vouloir avoir un coup de
possession faible mais quand on change
d'environnement et qu'on va vers une
situation géopolitique beaucoup plus
tendue et on veut avoir ses matériels
prêts on veut les équipages ou les
hommes et les femmes qui sont entraînés
qui soient prêts on a effectivement
besoin d'aller vers d'un niveau
d'activité fort voir un fort niveau de
disponibilité et là effectivement on
tombe sur des difficultés qui sont pas
qu'on utilise les matériels on les use
ça coûte cher à de les faire fonctionner
et donc là on tombe sur la l'opportunité
de regarder cas par cas système par
système quel est le meilleur type de MCO
qu'on peut donner et les contrats
verticalisés ont montré qu'ils étaient
très performants et très compétitif pour
amener des réponses à ces solutions là
donc je pense que ça reste du cas par
cas je pense que chaque système ou
chaque cas est vraiment spécifique et
que c'est un outil dans la boîte à
outils c'est un outil très important
qu'on n'a pas encore assez utilisé mais
qu'on commence à maîtriser justement et
qu'on va continuer à probablement à
améliorer et à utiliser plus largement
donc je pense que ces contrats sont une
façon de mieux répondre aux changements
d'environnement de s'adapter à la
situation dans laquelle on est où on
veut que les forces armées utilisent les
matériels utilisent les systèmes utilise
les capacités soit entraîner soit formés
et trouver la meilleure répartition du
travail à la meilleure coordination
entre les forces armées et les
industriels sur la façon de les mettre
en oeuvre et parfois il y a des raisons
de pas faire de contrat verticalisés
parce que les forces armées veulent
pouvoir projeter les matériels et les
mettre en oeuvre de façon indépendante
dans des environnements très hostiles
sans les industriels donc c'est vraiment
du cas par cas voilà donc le sujet du
coût de possession du coût d'emploi du
coût d'usage et de la disponibilité de
la vitesse à laquelle on va monter en
puissance pour les utiliser sont des
paramètres très importants qui sont
discutés à chaque fois qu'on regarde de
l'opportunité de verticaliser un contrat
et une fois encore je pense qu'on n'est
pas arrivé au bout de la démarche et
dans d'autres domaines que ceux de
l'aéro je sais que c'est en train de se
faire et là aussi il y a beaucoup de
potentiel
merci j'ai un rapporteurs sont
satisfaits juste peut-être Messieurs les
Présidents sur l'intervention éventuelle
de la DGA dans le PM
donc le la DGA est en train de se
réorganiser effectivement il y a et à
identifier
le MCO ou le maintien en conditions
procès comme une démission de la future
direction des opérations
je pense que le mouvement correspond à
une à une nécessité finalement de
concevoir des équipements qu'on peut
maintenir à coup objectif et avec un
outil industriel organisé donc c'est ce
souhait d'une
complémentarité entre le développement
et le MCO et d'éviter d'avoir des mondes
séparés après voilà c'est une
organisation en cours je pense qu'il y a
encore quelques étapes à passer mais
nous accompagnons nous accompagnerons le
mouvement que nous trouvons
effectivement positif
merci on va passer au programme 144
environnement et prospectif de la
politique de défense avec une
intervention unique de Yannick vogrenard
qui s'exprimera pour aussi pour le
compte de Patrick de Pascal à Lisa merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président a déjà été évoqué l'article 24
du projet de loi de BM je vais revenir
donc cet article prévoit la possibilité
d'imposer à certains industriels à
construction de stocks de matériaux et
de composants d'intérêts stratégique
ainsi que la priorisation de la
livraison de bien et services aux
bénéfice des armées qui dans le contexte
géopolitique bien entendu peut tout à
fait se comprendre monsieur Dermont tout
à l'heure vous évoquez la nécessité de
du travail en commun état administration
et industrie et du coup quel regard
portez-vous vous-même sur ces deux
dispositifs
avez-vous pu chiffrer le coup que ces
derniers pourront représenter pour vos
adhérents alors que s'agissant du
dispositif concernant les stocks
stratégiques au moment où nous parlons
aucune indemnisation n'est prévu pour
compenser les coûts liés à la
constitution et la l'immobilisation de
ces disques autre sujet donc avec Pascal
elzard qui ne pouvait être présent ce
matin nous présenterons la semaine
prochaine un rapport qui portera
notamment sur la question de l'accès aux
financement en particulier bancaire des
entreprises de l'habit TD si la mise en
place des référents défenses au sein des
banques et d'une médiatrice à la DGA est
encore récente avez-vous d'ores et déjà
des retours de vos adhérents sur ces
deux dispositifs récents
si les présidents
je vais peut-être juste répondre sur le
sujet de l'article 24 des stocks
je rappelle enfin c'est un sujet qu'on a
évoqué évidemment avec le ministère des
armées depuis un certain temps
ce sont des dispositifs qui existent on
avait comparé
et notamment au moment de la pandémie et
des premières difficultés
d'approvisionnement de matière première
ce qui se passait aux États-Unis ou là
la réquisition de stocks et de matière
pour la défense c'était inscrite dans la
loi et ça nous avait paru une bonne idée
donc le fait d'avoir une capacité de
privilégier des matières premières et de
faire des stocks pour servir les armées
et de toute évidence je crois que ça a
été dit par mes collègues et notamment
Guillaume Faury dans son intervention
c'est qu'à la fin il faut que
l'industrie soit associée aux conditions
de mise en oeuvre voilà pour que les
différents points ou mode de
fonctionnement soit clarifié pour que en
amont on sache à quoi s'attendre mais
pendant les moments difficiles de
matières premières j'ai parlé pour le
naval il y a eu un moment quand même et
notamment juste après le déclenchement
de la guerre en Ukraine où on a cru
qu'on allait manquer d'acier voilà et
bien l'industrie
a stocker de l'acier pour être capable
de livrer ses clients en France et
international au moment où on pouvait le
faire et puis ça nous a permis voilà
d'être en mesure de livrer donc voilà on
a déjà on fait des tas de choses le fait
d'avoir un article de loi je pense est
une bonne chose après c'est juste le le
la mise en place les modes d'allaité de
mise en oeuvre qu'il faut pouvoir
discuter alors soit au cas par cas soit
de manière générale voilà je crois que
c'est ce qu'on a dit sur l'accès aux
financement je vais en dire deux mots et
puis je laisserai peut-être marque
Darmon et G4 puisque les industries
terrestres de l'armement terrestre ont
souvent été confrontés à cette
difficulté voilà c'est peut-être plus
difficile quand on fait un canon ou un
obus de 155 quand on fait un bateau ou
un avion d'avoir accès à du financement
bancaire pour des raisons de SG de RSE
il faut pas enfin en tout cas la guerre
en Ukraine a quand même changé pas mal
les choses il faut le dire dans notre
environnement et en France on est plutôt
mieux loti qu'ailleurs
dans ce domaine là et ailleurs en Europe
donc ça c'est quand même deux choses que
je souhaitais dire après la mise en
place de médiateurs et de correspondant
a été une bonne chose bon mais donc si
il y a effectivement une amélioration il
faut pas se leurrer il y a toujours un
problème de fond et il y a toujours un
problème de fond auquel il faudra qu'on
soit vigilant et sans aucune naïveté
voilà
un certain nombre d'ONG continuent à
continuer à convaincre
du fait que la défense c'est pas bien
il y a ces tendances voilà guerre en
Ukraine ou pas qui continue à exister et
qui sont autour de nous donc souvent les
banquiers nous disent d'ailleurs nous on
peut et sur les banquiers français on
peut voilà prêter mais ça nous pose pas
de problème alors on demande à nos
d'être vigilant et de nous faire
remonter des problèmes mais ils nous
disent le problème c'est plutôt les
investisseurs et les investisseurs qui
ont des choix d'investissement qui
consistent par des règles de taxonomie
ou d'autres à d'exclure un certain
nombre de domaines et c'est vrai que la
défense le nucléaire sont des domaines
qui sont exclus d'un certain nombre de
portefeuille d'investisseurs parce
qu'ils préfèrent investir sur des sujets
qui sont peut-être plus facile ou qui
sont peut-être plus acceptables donc
alors nous avons un travail non
industrie de défense et ensemble puisque
c'est un travail collectif d'expliquer à
nos concitoyens d'expliquer notre
environnement qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de développement durable sans capacité
de se protéger et sans industrie de
défense donc pour moi pour nous
l'industrie de défense fait entièrement
partie du développement durable et de
l'avenir de nos sociétés mais voilà
soyons vigilants il y a un il y a une
réalité il y a un risque la guerre en
Ukraine a changé quelques mentalités
mais pas tout et puis il y a une
différence de point de vue entre ce qui
se passe aux États-Unis en Chine et dans
d'autres points du monde
je vais pas parler de la Russie ou de la
Turquie ou d'autres pays et de ce qui se
passe en Europe voilà l'Europe a
toujours envie d'être championne du
monde en tous les domaines et en
particulier dans celui-là voilà alors
mais en même temps je dis ça et en même
temps je constate que des améliorations
quand l'Europe achète en commun des
munitions quand Thierry Breton visite
des usines munitionnaires voilà ça
montre bien ça contribue à un état
d'esprit qui peut faire en sorte de
progresser sur le sujet du financement
bancaire
merci je vais peut-être essayer
d'apporter un éclairage sur le sujet de
la constitution des stocks qui est un
sujet évidemment important pour les
forces armées pour avoir une vitesse de
réactivité importante et on a vu que ça
avait manqué quand l'invasion en Ukraine
a eu lieu dans le domaine du civil c'est
quelque chose que nous faisons très
largement et nous faisons sur des bases
contractuelles entre clients et
fournisseurs quel stock de quel type de
produit financé de quelle façon est
toujours en ayant
en étant attentif à ce que ce qui soit
stocké
puisse être utilisé à un moment et non
pas qu'on stock des choses qui vont être
perdu de ce point de vue là c'est très
important d'être différenciant dans une
politique de stockage de matière
première qui partira toujours à un
moment ou un autre on sait qu'une
question d'immobilisation
par rapport à immobiliser et à mettre en
stock des biens finis si on met en stock
une tour Eiffel ou un porte-avion
nucléaire vous comprenez que c'est ça
marche pas donc c'est très important
d'arriver à avoir ce dialogue sur
qu'est-ce qu'on va vouloir mettre en
stock et puis comment on finance et de
ce point de vue là c'est un petit peu
inquiétant pour nous d'avoir le client
qui est aussi le régulateur
qui puisse imposer des stocks dont on
sait pas comment ils vont être utilisés
comment ils vont être quand est-ce que
si ils sont jamais utilisés qu'est-ce
qui se passe qui payent pour ça qui
prend le risque voilà quelle est la
relation contractuelle logique saine qui
permet de stocker de façon appropriée et
à des coûts qui soient raisonnables
parce que les coûts il va falloir les
porter d'une façon d'une autre et ces
sujets de relation contractuelles
toxique sur des stockages de bien
intermédiaires peut amener certaines
entreprises dans d'autres domaines à
sortir du business donc c'est
potentiellement quelque chose de
dangereux parce que ça pourrait amener
des entreprises à tellement
embêter tellement gêné sur la dimension
économique de l'activité dans ce domaine
là il y a simplement on voit plus dans
cette activité là on peut pas gagner
notre vie et aujourd'hui c'est un
différentiel qu'on voit se créer dans
nos métiers entre ce qui se passe dans
le domaine civil où il y a une
croissance très forte où il y a un
certain nombre de règles du jeu qui
permettent de prospérer et le domaine de
la défense en particulier en Europe et
aussi en France avec toutes les
contraintes qui nous sont mises où ça
devient de plus en plus difficile de
pouvoir faire des activités profitables
et pérennes et ça c'est potentiellement
une charge un risque un problème
supplémentaire donc on en comprend
l'objectif c'est des choses que nous
faisons nous-mêmes dans nos industries
d'avoir des stocks chez nos fournisseurs
donc on est tout à fait disposé en
parler mais il faut pas que ça soit
quelque chose qui soit un problème par
rapport au fait de faire l'activité il
faut que ça soit une solution une
solution aussi pour les industriels donc
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai dans mon
propos liminaire souhaité et mentionné
le besoin d'en discuter pour écrire la
façon dont ça va se passer et que ça
soit dans l'intérêt des forces AR Mées
bien compris et on ne change pas on ne
remet pas en cause l'objectif et
l'intérêt mais c'est très important de
trouver la bonne façon de le faire
vous vous n'allez pas l'effet de redit
puisque c'est les deux sujets que vous
avez aimé monsieur le rapporteur nous
concerne tous les trois très forts donc
pour pour sur le sujet des stocks en
complément de ce qu'on dit Pierre et
Gobelet Guillaume Faurie sur le besoin
aussi que nous participions à la
rédaction et aux échanges sur les sujets
vous avez beaucoup parlé du langage
financier qui est à contestable et que
bien compris ne pas oublier qu'il y a
aussi des enjeux opérationnels et même
industriels concrètement ces stocks où
les mettons ou les stocks t'ont il y a
des sujets de péremption que lorsqu'on
stocke du matériel pyrotechnique par
exemple donc concrètement que donc il y
a beaucoup de choses concrètes qui
méritent vraiment qu'on en parle en
détail et donc qui ont participé à la
rédaction des décrets et aux modalités
d'application sur le financement
effectivement comme le disait pierre et
Pommelet nous avons été les premiers
alertés même si demain ça touche
l'ensemble de l'industrie et attention
aux mirage depuis la guerre en Ukraine
on peut voir quelques éléments qui
montrent que ça se calme le problème de
fond est toujours là on a toujours
beaucoup
de reporting de sujets réels et de
sujets qui sont vraiment réels
c'est-à-dire il s'agit vraiment de
problèmes de financement non pas parce
que l'entreprise est en mauvaise
situation financière ou à des problèmes
de compléances mais vraiment des sujets
de domaine on en rencontre toujours il
faut encourager accompagner une
formation iadn d'ailleurs pour quelques
soit médiateurs soient membres de des
instituts bancaires peut être utile
attention on voit maintenant nous
remonter des problèmes avec les
assurances c'est un nouveau sujet donc
on va essayer de l'objectiviser pour
pour ne pas en parler comme ça mais mes
donner quelques exemples aux clés là on
touche plus que le financement en
capital ou le financement à
l'exportation là on est vraiment sur le
capacité opérationnelle ou industrielle
ne pas oublier bien sûr que comme dans
beaucoup de cas qui n'ont pas de rapport
mais il y a pas mal de sujets
d'objectivation difficile les
entreprises ont du mal à reporter le
sujet à se déclarer en difficulté avec
avec leur banquier
parmi les solutions une des solutions
évidemment la communication le soutien
de l'ensemble de la nation au sujet
communiquer positivement sur le sujet de
la défense
expliquer qu'en quoi l'industrie des
forces industrie durable industrie qui
protège nos valeurs notre démocratie de
la part de l'ensemble et notamment de
l'organisation populaire merci beaucoup
j'exclut pas du risque dans le futur on
lance la commission de lancer un rapport
sur ces problématiques du financement
des industries de défense parce que pas
se payer de mots dans ce genre
d'histoire
bien on a pas de questions
complémentaires des
146 équipement des forces avec Cédric
Perrin Hélène Conway merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les présidents
d'abord je vous remercie le président
d'avoir pris sa Nice cette initiative
parce qu'habituellement on se voit en
direct et ça permet aussi de partager
les nombreuses informations avec
l'ensemble des collègues c'est une bonne
chose que de pouvoir faire ça comme ça
j'étais dans une PME du côté d'Annecy la
semaine à 15 jours qui m'expliquait
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à assurer son
nouveau bâtiment une PME de la défense
évidemment 100% défense qui ne pouvait
pas assurer son nouveau bâtiment
monsieur le Président donc de nombreux
programmes subissent des étals mais
l'augmentation des crédits proposés par
la LPM est évidemment conséquente c'est
tellement qui parfois je l'ai dit et
peuvent ressembler à des renoncements
c'est le cas du programme scorpion
puisque la cible des griffons est en
baisse de 30 % à 2030 de même que la
cible des Jaguar ou des servales c'est
aussi le cas pour la filière
aéronautique avec le Rafale ou la 401 ou
encore monsieur le Président les
incertitudes sur le Tigre puisque nous
n'arrimons pas à avoir d'informations
très concrètes sur le sujet
marque de plus sous marque 3 qui semble
abandonner dans le domaine naval
également la FDI ou les FDI ou le slam F
pourquoi nous avons un peu de mal à
comprendre certaines affirmations du
ministre des armées sur les
augmentations de chiffre d'affaires qui
seraient générés par cette LPM le
ministre a affirmé ici par exemple que
arcus allait voir son chiffre d'affaires
augmenter de 40%, ce qui semble étonné
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs aujourd'hui
mais voilà peut-être vous nous donner
quelques informations sur ces sur ces
sujets
quel est votre réponse donc au ministre
sur ces différents points quels sont les
comptes très concrètement les
conséquences des étalement
et puis il a été évoqué le président l'a
dit tout à l'heure très largement que la
raison notamment de la diminution des
cibles ou des étalons de programme était
du fait de la responsabilité des
entreprises qui n'étaient pas en
capacité de produire suffisamment
rapidement ou insuffisamment gros volume
là aussi j'aimerais beaucoup que vous
puissiez nous donner quelques éléments
quels sont les perspectives en tout cas
sur vos activités vos emplois et la
pérennité des compétences sur les sites
industriels que cette LPM va pouvoir
apporter en deuxième lieu les reports de
cible pour les grands programmes allège
évidemment les factures annuelles pour
l'État mais par la suite ils sont
évidemment nécessairement un coût du
fait de la baisse des volumes et donc de
la diminution de l'économies d'échelle
sur les programmes de quel ordre et ce
coût pourriez-vous nous donner des
exemples concrets sur des ordres de
grandeur sur les augmentations du coût
liées au programme et à l'heure
étalement la troisième question porte
sur les relations entre les PME et les
grands maîtres d'oeuvre industrielle les
grandes entreprises
nous ferons vraisemblablement les
étalement avec plus ou moins de
difficultés mais qu'en sera-t-il des PME
et des ETI quel sera l'impact sur de la
LPM sur le tissu industriel que font les
principaux maîtres d'oeuvre pour donner
davantage de visibilité au PME il y a eu
une dizaine d'années le pacte défense
PME qui mettait en place un certain
nombre de mesures et d'engagement
vis-à-vis des sous-traitants est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un mot ou un
essai de démarche aujourd'hui et enfin
le Chantier de l'économie de guerre se
poursuit depuis maintenant presque un an
la loi de programmation militaire
prévoit plusieurs dispositifs à ce sujet
est-ce que vous pourriez nous indiquer
qu'elles ont été les concertations avec
les entreprises puisque une somme qui
ait eu un certain nombre de réunions en
tout cas avec les 7 grosses entreprises
les PME ne semblent pas du tout avoir
été en tout cas de celle qu'on rencontre
associée à ces discussions
sur le fond quel est votre appréciation
du texte proposé ce texte est-il
suffisamment équilibré ou suscite-t-il
de votre part des remarques à titre
personnel et après les différentes
auditions qu'on a pu faire avec ma
collègue Hélène sur le PC 46 je suis
très très dubitatif sur l'article 24 sur
ses conséquences et je pense pouvoir le
juger assez inopérant pour l'instant
ces dispositions vous paraissent-elles
applicables et en évoquant une
éventuelle priorité pour les clients
français ne risque-t-on pas de nuire aux
perspectives d'exportation des
entreprises alors qu'on aurait peut-être
pu aboutir au même résultat par d'autres
moyens
dernier point c'est celui des appels
d'offres aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que compte tenu de
l'évolution des nouvelles technologies
et de l'agilité nécessaire à la mise en
oeuvre de ces nouvelles technologies il
est nécessaire de réfléchir en tout cas
de mon point de vue à un nouveau moyen
de pouvoir accélérer les dispositifs
aujourd'hui 18 mois pour un appel
d'offres ça aboutit au fait que quand
l'appel d'offre est conclusif la
technologie est obsolète comment est-ce
que vous alors ça dépend aussi
évidemment des des industries mais
comment est-ce que vous imaginez qu'on
pourrait réfléchir à des solutions
alternatives merci beaucoup
merci Cédric Hélène Conway
merci président merci pour vos propos
Messieurs les Présidents je crois qu'on
posait très clairement les priorités
pour vous dans un texte qui propose
finalement de tout faire
l'intérêt étant plutôt bien sûr de bien
faire
Cédric Perrin est envahi allié les
questions qui a mis nos réflexions en
préparation de l'examen du texte je vais
vous emmener au niveau européen qui est
une dimension dimension importante et
chère à Guillaume Faury mais à nous tous
et toutes
avec une Union européenne qui mène ses
propres travaux sur l'économie de guerre
qui est une expression maintenant qui
semble être passée dans le le langage
commun avec des objectifs concrets
d'augmentation des volumes et de
réduction des délais d'approvisionnement
munition pour l'Ukraine donc on est bien
économie de guerre c'est-à-dire plus et
plus vite alors le plan européen qu'on
porte pardon plusieurs volets tout
d'abord le financement d'achat en commun
23 pays au moins en rejoint le programme
d'acquisition conjointe de munitions
qu'elle vous avait fait référence qui
sera mise en oeuvre par l'Agence
européenne de défense ensuite ce plan
vise l'augmentation des capacités de
production de l'industrie et
sécurisation des chaînes
d'approvisionnement grâce à un
financement de lieu et à une série de
dérogations réglementaire ce qui semble
finalement aller dans le sens de ce que
vous proposez tous les trois d'un besoin
de visibilité alors question quel est
votre appréciation de façon générale sur
les instruments qui sont mis en place
par l'UE et leur modalités de mise en
oeuvre comment les avancées européennes
s'articulent-elles avec le chantier
français de l'économie de guerre
et Cédric vient de rappeler en effet que
nous consacrons beaucoup d'heures de
d'audition
préparation bien sûr de l'examen du
texte et nous notons quand même un
certain regret exprimé par nos nombre de
nos interlocuteurs sur un manque de
consultation en amont finalement de la
préparation de ce texte donc j'aimerais
savoir si aujourd'hui vous avez des
concertations avec le ministère des
armées et qui sont en cours et en
particulier avec la DGA
deuxième point l'ancien 2021 le plan
France 2030 consacre 54 milliards
d'euros à l'investissement dans les
technologies innovantes dans le cadre de
diggrans objectifs relatifs à la
décorbanisation des carbonations c'est
mieux et au progrès des connaissances ce
plan n'a pas vocation à financer le
secteur de la défense mais il peut
financer les domaines duo en particulier
dans l'exploration des fonds marins et
le spatial mais aussi pour tout ce qui
la transition énergétique les
financement du Plan 2030 ne pourrait-il
pas profiter davantage à l'abbé TD dans
la plupart des entreprises sont dues
comment accompagnez-vous les entreprises
pour rechercher ces financements la DGA
se conserve-t-elle suffisamment avec le
secrétariat général pour
l'investissement pour faire jouer les
synergies entre différents financements
et enfin les entreprises de la BITD
vont-elles se positionner pour
bénéficier du plan French tech 2030 du
ministère de l'Économie et enfin pour
revenir à l'article 24 quand même qui
semble poser quelques problèmes vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure l'impact
négatif pour pour les exportations si le
était d'adopter en l'état quel serait
les d'autres conséquences finalement
concrètes de cet article d'autres
exemples que vous pouvez peut-être avoir
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a des
compromis possibles pour l'écriture des
décrets je vous remercie
monsieur le Président allons-y
je commence par des réponses à quelques
éléments
un mot sur ce que vous avez appelé les
étalement monsieur le sénateurs donc si
on précis par exemple la cible de
scorpion la cible de scorpion n'est pas
modifiée ce qui est modifié c'est sa
livraison pour 2030 je joue pas sur les
mots mais inversement en termes de
visibilité si la cible est peut modifier
c'est aussi un élément de visibilité je
vais pas défendre le fait qu'on réduise
les cadences mais mais en revanche je
voulais juste être précis sur l'élément
cela veut dire donc c'est donc un
compromis entre entre cette capacité
Scorpion et d'autres capacités sur
lesquelles les armées notamment l'armée
terre va investir sur le chiffre
d'affaires je ne sais pas répondre à
votre question précise sur arcus mais
LPM en augmentation veut bien dire
chiffre d'affaires d'augmentation il n'y
a pas de il y a pas de qui votent
là-dessus
par définition en revanche effectivement
puisqu'on veut traiter plus de choses de
nouveau de nouvelles capacités ou de vos
champs de conflictualité comme la lutte
dans le cyberespace dans la lune dans de
la formation puis des nouvelles menaces
forcément il a fallu faire des choix je
dis pas ça pour défendre l'ensemble mais
pour vraiment être précis sur les mots
donc notamment sur ce scorpion la cible
des bonnes modifier et une augmentation
de la LPM de façon d'ailleurs continue
depuis 5 ans et pour les 5 ans qui
viennent amène naturellement à une
relation de chiffre d'affaires en tout
cas de l'industrie au sens large même si
individuellement ça peut amener à la
différence moi j'aurais dire un mot sur
les PME d'abord les PME ont été
représentés dans l'ensemble des
séminaires économiques guerre puisque
ces séminaires réunissaient les 7 ou 8
grands patrons d'entreprises aux
défenses et les groupements notamment
nous trois donc moi-même étant
représentant uniquement les PME même
certains séminaires ont aussi réunis des
représentants de PME c'est le cas y
compris dans le Super séminaire organisé
par le Président de la République dans
lequel les PME aussi ont pu s'exprimer
en l'occurrence à travers à travers ma
parole sur pour ce qui est de
l'industrie terrestre donc elles ont été
représentés et les PME font partie
complète de la réflexion sur l'économie
de guerre je prends un exemple qui est
le ce qu'on appelle le diagnostic cyber
diagnostic cybersécurité qui est imposée
à la supplation pour justement renforcer
la résilience de notre société et qui a
été je dirais normalisé par la
Délégation Générale pour l'Armement ce
diagnostic cyber en fait il sert peu au
grand groupe qui eux-mêmes ont leur
politique leur pratique leur
fournisseurs leur labels il sert
beaucoup pour les hôteliers les PME et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elle nous disent
que le trouve ça bienvenue à la fois
pour la montée en niveau et le fait que
justement il y a une mesure pour ce pour
se mesurer donc il y a pas mal d'actions
qui sont faites autour des PME je
rappelle notamment dans le domaine
terrestre beaucoup de PME ne sont pas
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement ne
sont pas la suppression ils sont souvent
en contact direct avec l'administration
et là aussi elles ont besoin de
visibilité sur les programmes en direct
voilà un peu peut-être revenir sur ces
j'imagine que dans vos auditions
évidemment vous discutez de ces
questions de cible de besoin de matériel
etc avec les armées qui sont quand même
les premiers à exprimer des besoins et
vos incapacité moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que l'industrie est
aujourd'hui en matière de réponse alors
c'est sûr que si on nous demandait de
livrer deux sous-marins nucléaires
d'attaque par an ce serait un peu
compliqué quand même mais enfin je vous
rassure ce n'est pas le cas mais notre
industrie navale va quand même livrer un
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque en 2023
et un autre en 2024 donc avec un outil
industriel extraordinairement performant
et j'ai dit qu'on allait livrer tous les
sous-marins conformément à ce qui est
prévu aujourd'hui dans la programmation
d'ici à la fin de la décennie voilà donc
les cibles sont maintenues certains
programmes pour des raisons évidemment
liées aux besoins militaires aux
capacités budgétaires et aux arbitrages
qui sont faits revoir leur calendrier
mais si maintenant je regarde sur les
bâtiments de surface
l'impact sur nos sites sur nos bureaux
d'études sur nos activités industrielles
sera avoir avec la charge à
l'exportation que nous aurons aussi à
réaliser
nos chantiers sont des chantiers
exportateurs
naval group par exemple 30 % de son
activité ou 35 % de notre activité à
l'exportation certains chantiers navals
ont une activité exportation extrêmement
importante qui n'est pas 60 70 % et donc
c'est bien le complément entre la charge
et la visibilité liée à cette loi de
programmation militaire et le calendrier
prévu est-ce que nous serons capables
ensemble de gagner l'exportation qui
fera notre activité industrielle et à la
fin qui permettra de dire si oui ou non
l'outil industriel des livres ou si oui
ou non l'outil industriel a un problème
de capacité parce que c'est vrai que
pour livrer sur le long terme nous
devons maintenir un certain nombre de
compétences et on peut pas descendre
trop bas donc mais ça c'est un dialogue
permanent que nous avons avec le
ministère des armées on a parlé tout à
l'heure de la fabrication des dégâts la
DG créer une direction des entreprises
et qui sera notre interlocuteur au jour
le jour pour discuter de la visibilité
des plancharges des compétences
nécessaires et de notre capacité à
livrer j'ai cité trois fois le mot de
compétences et donc maintenant juste
élaborer un peu plus parce qu'on parle
souvent de capacités industrielle je
rappelle d'abord où je rappelle aussi
que la première capacité dont on a
besoin c'est bien la compétence et bien
la ressource humaine vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui l'industrie est
confrontée à des problématiques de
recrutement dans tous nos domaines parce
que on a de l'activité et puis parce que
après avoir pendant tant d'années décrié
l'industrie il est pas étonnant que les
jeunes générations se posent des
questions ainsi que leur famille pour
venir travailler dans l'industrie alors
ça se retourne depuis quelques temps
quelques années et en ce moment mais ça
sera long d'aller convaincre nos jeunes
de venir travailler chez nous donc là
aussi on parlait tout à l'heure de
parler positivement de la défense pour
convaincre les investisseurs de nous
amener de l'argent parce que nous avons
tous le devoir de parler positivement de
l'industrie et de l'industrie de défense
pour pouvoir convaincre les jeunes
générations de venir faire ce que nous
demande la nation c'est-à-dire le livret
les équipements qui sont prévus dans les
lois de programmation
je vais juste l'anecdote concernant
naval Group et notre industrie nous
sommes une industrie déjà nous sommes
ainsi défense et Nasri qui fait du
nucléaire
vous pouvez pas de la je vous fais pas
de dessin il y a quelques années était
industrie défense et nucléaire combinait
quand même trois handicaps qui en est un
peu difficile les amphis ou les forums
dans les lycées ou dans les écoles pour
venir travailler ça c'était il y a
quelques années
la situation aujourd'hui et que
l'industrie reprend des couleurs en tout
cas dans le débat public que la défense
reprend des couleurs et vous y
contribuez et que le nucléaire aussi
reprend des couleurs donc je suis
optimiste sur notre capacité à faire
venir ses compétences dont on a besoin
pour demain et qui sont extrêmement
importantes vous avez parlé d'économie
de guerre bon pour moi l'économie de
guerre c'est
outre les mots et mais c'est d'abord un
état d'esprit et c'est un état d'esprit
un dialogue il y a il y a il y a eu il y
a des groupes de travail le sujet de la
simplification qui est abordé dans
l'économie de guerre n'est pas un sujet
futile et je peux vous assurer qu'on a
la porte ouverte aujourd'hui avec la DGA
et le ministère des armées si on a des
bonnes idées de simplification quelle
qu'elle soit dans l'environnement norm
dans l'environnement documentaire
industriels etc la DGA et le DG à
lui-même nous ouvre ses portes
on a beaucoup parlé dans l'économie de
guerre aussi de d'efficacité
industrielle de résilience de ce planète
vous parlez des PME la DG a mené un
travail assez complet de PME dite
critique c'est-à-dire celle qui pouvait
avoir un problème en cas de monter en
cadence ou qui avait une situation un
peu compliquée parce que moyen de
production unique etc
plusieurs centaines d'entreprises ont
été identifiées chacun d'entre nous a sa
liste d'entreprise avec qui on a un
dialogue tout particulier donc ce n'est
pas futile je ne suis pas surpris que un
certain nombre de PME disent de ne pas
être associés quand on voit le nombre de
PME dans notre domaine mais je peux vous
assurer que nos groupements sont aussi
le lieu de fédération de ce que les PME
pensent et que on amène à la DG au
ministère des armées pour améliorer les
choses voilà
ce que je voulais dire donc sur les
cibles je pense d'abord on n'a pas
encore nous commencé la discussion dans
le détail et pour cause parce qu'il y a
une étape parlementaire nécessaire avant
mais je suis confiant sur le fait que
nous amènerons à la DGA et au ministère
des armées toutes les problématiques
posées en termes de charge industrielle
et je me répète à la lumière aussi de ce
qu'on sera capable de gagner ensemble à
l'international
c'est n'importe quel compléments sans
redire ce qui a été dit je pense que
très précisément sur le Tigre marque 3
qu'on l'appelle Marc de plus ou marque 3
en tout cas le la redéfinition qui en a
été faite avec la France et l'Espagne on
a une solution qui fonctionne mais qui
m'a l'air stabilisé donc je pense que ça
c'est un point qui est réglé en ce qui
concerne la 401 la cible qui a été
mentionnée au moins 35 n'est pas le
chiffre du contrat donc ça matérialise
un certain nombre de questions ou de
réflexions sur la façon de gérer cet
écart entre les deux et je crois que le
débat en ce moment avec la DGA avec les
forces armées et le ministère est au bon
endroit à savoir comment arriver à
accompagner la 400m à l'export pour se
donner de la flexibilité sur la façon
dont les slots de production vont être
utilisés parce que tout le monde a la
volonté de garder l'outil industriel à
400m vivant c'est absolument essentiel
c'est c'est le seul appareil
qui permet de faire toutes ces missions
absolument cruciales pour les opérations
du monde dans lequel on est l'opération
logistique tactique en environnement
hostile et donc je crois que tout le
monde a cette volonté très forte de
garder ce programme conjoint entre
partenaires
capables de livrer et également de
réussir à l'export mais de rester
pérenne dans le temps donc il y a du
travail à faire il est en cours de
discussion et avec une volonté partagée
trouver les bonnes solutions
j'ai entendu à plusieurs endroits des
questions sur l'articulation entre les
grands groupes les PME entre le civil et
le militaire peut-être je vais un tout
petit peu de recul pour partager avec
vous que ogif face c'est à dire dans le
groupement de l'industrie aéronautique
et spatial civile et militaire on a fait
en fait face depuis trois ans un peu
plus de trois ans maintenant à plusieurs
chocs et on l'a fait en filière
le covid était existentiel pour cette
filière c'est à dire que la dimension
militaire s'est retrouvée mise en danger
par une crise d'une nature qui avait
rien à voir avec le militaire parce que
la performance de notre industrie
aujourd'hui est lié à son caractère de
Halle le militaire prend énormément
d'effets d'échelle du civil et le civil
prend des investissements dans certaines
technologies d'humidité donc cette
complémentarité elle est assez
exceptionnelle elle fonctionne très très
bien et aujourd'hui on l'a fait bien
fonctionner on a eu énormément de
discussions de dispositif de
d'accompagnement parfois de financement
sur des domaines civils qui ont été
bénéficiaires à toutes les entreprises
qui sont actives dans le domaine
militaire et qui ont pu rester vivante
et continuer à assumer leurs engagements
dans le domaine militaire parce que le
domaine civil trouvé ses solutions et on
a aujourd'hui on est en train de mettre
derrière nous progressivement la crise
du covid qui a été prolon la plus
difficile à gérer
l'Ukraine et le changement de
perspective géopolitique amène aussi un
certain nombre de changements il est
important dans dans ces périodes très
agitée que les axes de d'investissement
les axes de dépenses les axes de
recherche qui sont définis soit tenus
dans le temps une discussion très
importante aujourd'hui sur le
financement du Corax c'est-à-dire la
recherche civile parce que énormément de
PME en bénéficient elles ont embauché
elles ont investi pour être capable de
faire cette décarbonation qui est
absolument essentielle dans le domaine
civil mais qui entraîne beaucoup de
technologie et beaucoup
d'investissements qui sont également
utiles enfin qui ont des retombées très
positives pour ces entreprises dans leur
capacité à assumer leur mission
militaire à être innovantes avoir des
bureaux d'études amener des solutions
compétitives donc ce modèle dual il est
très spécifique mais il est très
performant
à la fois la dimension civile et la
dimension militaire doivent être gérées
et ogif face je pense qu'on peut
raisonnablement dire que c'est très bien
fait les PME sont très contentes de du
forum qu'elle trouve elles sont souvent
questionnées challenger elle dit
systématiquement et c'était on a encore
rediscuté hier quels sont très
bénéficiaires de ce qui se passe et donc
l'articulation grand fabricant en grande
constructeurs au im ou donneur d'ordre
j'aime pas beaucoup ce terme-là et
entreprise de taille intermédiaire au
plus petites fonctionnent bien on
fonctionne vraiment en groupe
et c'est une vraie réalité qu'on fait
vivre
sur sur les étals
il faut qu'on s'adapte on a vu des
étalement beaucoup plus violents avec le
covid dans le domaine civil donc on sait
faire des talents évidemment ça a des
coûts évidemment ça a des conséquences
nous ce qu'on demande juste c'est de
pouvoir en discuter contrat par contrat
programme par programme et trouver des
solutions qui soient qui soit viable et
je pense que c'est le type de relation
qu'on a et qu'on est capable de faire
fonctionner
sur l'article 24
j'ai essayé d'être clair au début dans
ce que j'ai dit
je pense que le diable est dans les
détails pensons n'a pas encore été dans
les détails je pense que le principe de
l'article 24 je le comprends je le
partage je vous dis on le fait dans le
civil pour qu'on le ferait pas dans le
militaire simplement dans le militaire
on a affaire à une situation où le
client et le régulateur si l'impose des
stocks qui sont toxiques alors on crée
quelque chose de négatif mais on a
encore devant nous le temps pour écrire
les détails de façon à ce que ça soit
positif et que ça fonctionne mais je
vois pas de raison pourquoi on y
arriverait pas mais il faut créer les
conditions de ce dialogue et de la
structuration de d'un texte qui
fonctionne donc je suis optimiste mais
on a le on a le boulot à faire
il y a eu des questions importantes qui
ont été posées sur l'articulation entre
les instruments européens et les
instruments français je pense que je ne
serai pas honnête en vous disant que ça
fonctionne bien aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué c'est sur des plans assez
différents il y a des vraies intentions
européennes donner des outils d'amener
d'investissement d'amener la capacité
d'accompagnement donc c'est pas les
intentions qui sont en cause c'est plus
effectivement la façon de le réaliser et
il y a énormément de complexité et cette
complexité elle est souvent assez
décourageante parfois contre-productive
et puis
nous sommes dans nos industries dans un
environnement européen ou l'industrie
est pas toujours très bien soutenue on a
en face de nous des Américains qui sont
très très soutenus dans leur industrie
par le gouvernement américain et par la
politique et par les lois et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est parfois on se sent
fragilisé par des dispositifs qui
ouvrent la porte en plus pour que de
l'argent européen aille vers des
sociétés non-européennes ou des filiales
européennes de société non européenne et
donc on voit aussi une forme de
fragilisation de la européenne pour
répondre rapidement à des besoins
européens ou de l'argent européen et
demi donc le fait de tout faire en
européen est compliqué et moi j'aime
bien nuancer en partageant l'idée que se
mettre entre européen quelques-uns pour
créer une masse critique 2 3 4 5 autour
d'un projet particulier mais nos efforts
en commun notre argent en commun pour
avoir un effet d'échelle beaucoup plus
fort c'est très positif vouloir faire
systématiquement les choses à l'échelle
européenne au sens Bruxelles ça rend
parfois les choses extrêmement
compliquées et le terrain de jeu a créé
pour que chacun puisse trouver sa place
c'est très compliqué et donc aujourd'hui
je pense que on n'est pas un point de
réglage qui est optimal je pense que
c'est encore compliqué ça m'étonnerait
ça m'intéresserait de coûter mes
collègues aussi c'est encore compliqué
de trouver une bonne articulation entre
le National le multinational entre pays
européens et Bruxelles et la dimension
UE et ça c'est un niveau de complexité
qui rend les choses
problématiques dans beaucoup de
programmes et beaucoup d'affaires et
donc il y a encore du travail il faut
encore je ne remets pas en cause les
intentions je pense que les intentions
sont les bonnes mais la mise en œuvre
est très complexe
peut-être un mot puisque vous avez
évoqué France 2030 tous les moyens de
financement finalement qui sont mis en
place pour développer et pérenniser
l'industrie c'est vrai que beaucoup et
Guillaume forêt l'a rappelé beaucoup de
nos entreprises sont dues et nos
entreprises participent au CSF au comité
stratique de filière avec des outils qui
permettent d'accéder à des programmes
qui sont financés par France de migrants
ou d'autres ou d'autres moyens de
financement venant d'autres ministères
que le ministère des armées voilà donc
nous le faisons et les domaines que vous
avez cités sont ceux sur lequel des
projets aujourd'hui existent le domaine
des fonds marins et la maîtrise des
fonds marins avec tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer autour et la transition
énergétique alors on parle beaucoup de
la transition énergétique dans le
domaine de l'aéronautique je peux vous
dire que si dans le naval c'est un sujet
de grande actualité parce que 90% du
commerce mondial se faisant par les
maires le domaine naval ne peut pas être
exclu plutôt sur le domaine civil ne pas
être exclu dans la transition
énergétique je rappelle registre mais là
c'est pour l'anecdote que dans le
domaine militaire nous faisons où nous
apprêtons à faire avec la loi de
programmation militaire un navire de
75000 tonnes zéro émission donc à ce
titre là nous contribuons à la
transition énergétique du domaine naval
très bien
avec les rapporteurs j'ai trois
intervenants pour des questions minutes
Mickaël Valley
monsieur le Président j'avais une
première question sur l'économie de
guerre mais il en a déjà été question
souligne juste que au delà des mots
est-ce que ça peut créer dans l'opinion
la Seconde Guerre mondiale c'était 40 %
du PIB américain qui était dédié donc
voilà toujours parlant des mots le patch
qui est un terme qui doit vouloir dire
chapitre le patch cyber est estimé à 4
milliards d'euros dans la LPM et c'est
un sujet finalement que vous n'avez
évoqué qu'en filigrane ou très très peu
tout à l'heure ça a été évoqué une
seconde fois donc la question c'est de
votre point de vue quel est notre degré
de dépendance ou pour employer les
grands mots de souveraineté dans le
domaine notamment vis-à-vis du matériel
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
question de l'acier sur laquelle il y a
eu une tension inquiétude qu'en est-il
sur sur le cyber et sur ce cet
approvisionnement là quels sont de votre
point de vue le ou les programmes
majeurs sur lesquels on peut mettre un
coup de projecteur
utilement et puis enfin avec mon
collègue Olivier Cadic dans les dans les
rencontres de terrain qu'on fait en ce
moment ce qui nous remonte
systématiquement c'est que ce soit dans
le civil dans le militaire quel que soit
le degré d'implication des structures
que nous voyons c'est le problème de
recrutement y compris même dans le
public où on se on bataille pour
recruter des des techniciens des
sachants d'une d'un organisme à l'autre
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure monsieur
notamment dans le domaine naval la
difficulté de recrutement d'un industrie
mais dans le domaine cyber est-ce que
vous sentez cette tension de la même
façon est-ce que vous arrivez à trouver
des solutions pour recruter comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure vous même du
technicien spécialisé jusqu'à
l'ingénieur quel est le degré de tension
et est-ce que ça vous inquiète autant
que ce qu'on entend dans dans d'autres
domaines que ce soit dans le public ou
dans le privé
si je vais prendre le relais du
président et vous demander de répondre
directement avant la prochaine question
merci beaucoup
je vais prendre la réponse attention
donc au vocabulaire est très important
et je veux pas à nouveau jeu sur le
moule le mot cyber tout court on peut
dire numérique donc on parle en fait de
cyberespace en fait ce qui est prévu
dans le fameux chapitre et plusieurs
éléments d'abord une cyber résilience et
notamment une cyber résilience de notre
industrie et de notre suppression c'est
un élément particulier c'est le seul que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure effectivement
sur la capacité de protéger nos
opérations les grands groupes la Supply
chaîne nous promet de seconde au
troisième rang beaucoup d'éléments sont
présents à tous au travers le pacte
cyber le cyber diagnostic et de toute
façon générale la sensibilisation par
les maîtres d'oeuvre de leur supply
chaîne et puis de la de l'administration
de la suppression donc ce premier sujet
c'est la cyber résidence le deuxième
c'est d'une façon générale la lutte dans
le cyberespace donc pour beaucoup de
raisons je me je m'étendrai pas mais la
lutte pour super espace et bien sûr la
cyberdéfense le pas seulement et le
troisième élément qui est très important
c'est la protection contre les
cyberattaques de nos systèmes d'armoires
pour lequel est d'ailleurs une bonne
partie de l'importance de l'action et
faites là et là ça concerne absolument
tous les milieux de s'assurer que nos
systèmes d'armes ont une composante de
cyberprotection à l'intérieur détection
intervention résolution etc et donc cet
ensemble là qui qui est concernée par le
fameux chapitre donc une fois qu'on a
dit ça deux choses il y a quelques
années c'était facile de dire que on
avait des problèmes de revêtement dans
le domaine de la cybersécurité et de la
cyberdéfense c'est c'est bien sûr
toujours vrai c'est un problème mondial
il est malheureusement rattrapé par
quasiment tout le reste de l'industrie
et de l'industrie de défense donc il y a
10 ans c'était un problème particulier
pour le numérique à la cybersécurité
aujourd'hui c'est un problème qui est
beaucoup plus large de l'ensemble des
secteurs de dans le domaine de la
défense donc je veux pas susciter de
l'armement particulier pour la
cybersécurité mais bien sûr on a besoin
qui est supérieur à la ressource et
supérieure à ce qui sort des écoles
c'est incontestable donc ça c'est le
premier élément le deuxième inversement
en cybersécurité et en action dans le
domaine du cyberespace on n'a pas
arrangé en France vous parliez de
souveraineté d'autonomie on n'a pas
arrosé en France ça vient d'une autre
système d'enseignement supérieur les
grandes écoles et l'intérêt pour les
mathématiques que l'on est en France
avec probablement des entreprises qui
sont leader sur leur marché au moins en
Europe si ce n'est plus dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité au sens large et là
aussi un écosystème extrêmement large de
grands groupes leader de PME de TI je
vous savez plus de ma charge du JK
la chance de présider l'industrie de
sécurité de cybersécurité civile en
France et l'industrie extrêmement
dynamique donc la première raison c'est
là la seconde c'est le niveau d'exigence
de nos administrations que ce soit le
ministère des armées que ce soit Lancy
Winston intérieur et le gdsm en terme de
protection et de sécurité notamment de
nos opérateurs d'importance vitales et
ce niveau plutôt plus élevé que nos que
nos partenaires européens fait qu'on a
une industrie en France qui est de bon
niveau
alors je vais le guerillom et l'âme oui
merci beaucoup moi aussi je voulais
revenir sur cette question de
recrutement et de compétences parce que
vous savez que dans la LPM il y a la
possibilité d'ouverture d'une réserve
industrie hier qui est au-delà de
l'armée mais qui serait mise au service
de l'industrie donc je voulais savoir si
vous aviez déjà fait des estimations à
ce sujet parce que ce problème de
recrutement est énorme c'est le
président de Thalès qui disait dans une
interview il y a deux mois que nous
aurions besoin de deux fois plus
d'ingénieurs en France vous avez
commencé à faire des partenariats avec
des grandes écoles et je pense à l'Est
sec par exemple qui est une très bonne
idée mais bon voilà où en êtes-vous sur
de ce point de vue là deuxièmement je
voudrais remercier Monsieur Marc pommelé
qui a parlé de diplomatie parlementaire
concept qui nous est cher que nous
essayons de mettre en oeuvre dans le
cadre d'assemblées parlementaire par
exemple comme le temps parce que nous
avons un travail influence à faire et
par des visites de terrain nous étions
tout récemment au Brésil et sur les
plateaux d'aiguillages où il y a un
potentiel absolument énorme notamment en
Guyane vous le savez mais au Brésil
aussi et je dois vraiment remercier
féliciter le travail qui a été fait en
amont avec vos personnels et tout ce qui
est fait au Brésil sur la base dites à
gouailles les Brésiliens sont ravis de
ce qui a été fait mise en demande encore
plus avec un sous-marin nucléaire vous
le savez il compte un peu sur nous pour
pousser le dossier et enfin petite
question l'allemand reinstalla
reinstalle a décidé de mettre en place
une usine de production en Ukraine dans
un accord avec
ucho Brom prank est-ce que vous vous
avez l'intention de mettre en place des
usines sur le sol
ukrainien pour répondre à la demande et
pour préparer l'avenir aussi puisqu'il y
aura une grosse construction à faire
merci
Messieurs les Présidents
voilà je pense que sur LA dernière
question c'est une question qui
s'adresse aux industriels
individuellement en fonction de leur
stratégie c'est difficile pour un
groupement d'y répondre dans le cadre
d'une politique publique
voilà sur la réserve industrielle donc
on soutient l'idée depuis le début
puisque c'est un sujet qui est sur la
table depuis un certain temps après
c'est bien évidemment les modalités mais
le fait de pouvoir avoir des ressources
et des compétences mobilisables en cas
de besoin dans le cas d'une réserve est
une bonne idée voilà après c'est c'est
les modalités de mise en oeuvre qui
devront être qui devront être discutés
mais en tout cas l'industrie accueille
évidemment cette mesure de manière
favorable le sujet du recrutement ne me
concerne pas que les ingénieurs ça
concerne absolument toutes les
catégories et ça concerne toute
l'industrie voilà c'est et je l'ai dit
il y a des raisons un peu historiques à
ce qui a été industrie souvent vu par
les plans sociaux et par un peu une
image négative des usines et donc on a
un énorme travail autour de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sous le vocabbrien
industrialisation pour faire connaître à
nos concitoyens quels sont aujourd'hui
des métiers de l'industrie qui sont des
métiers formidables dans tous les
domaines quels sont les carrières
qu'elles offrent les développements
voilà le travail de l'objet il y a un
environnement public qui est favorable
charge à nous dans faire un
environnement enfin en tout cas une
action
envers tous nos concitoyens nous menons
des actions je crois les uns et les
autres j'ai juste donné un exemple de ce
qu'on fait avec EDF et Orano dans la
région de Cherbourg où nous avons décidé
ensemble à trois étant donné les besoins
de du domaine nucléaire qu'il soit civil
ou militaire de créer une école de
soudure là donc trois industries qui
mutualisent leurs moyens pour créer une
école pour former des soudeurs mais qui
auront vocation à aller travailler dans
l'industrie nucléaire qu'elle soit
civile ou militaires alors c'est un
exemple il y a énormément d'actions
comme celle-là qui sont menées dans les
territoires avec l'Éducation nationale
avec lui et même avec nos branches avec
les uns et les autres et voilà je pense
que
c'est une absolue nécessité je vous dis
pour être capable de faire ce qu'on aura
à faire demain
souvent la première matière qui nous
manque ou crise de nous manquer c'est
bien la matière grise quelle qu'elle
soit
je vais juste en rajouter mais peut-être
mettre un peu plus de couleurs liées à
notre propre industrie
après le covid on est remonté en cadence
très fortement et aujourd'hui le facteur
limitant numéro 1 c'est ce qu'on appelle
la Supply Chain la capacité de la chaîne
de fournisseur à répondre à la demande
si je prends le cas des bus l'année
dernière on voulait livrer 720 avions on
en a livré 660 et c'est pas parce que
les clients étaient pas là ils se
bousculent c'est parce que les
fournisseurs n'étaient pas capables de
répondre et si 160 c'est 200 avions de
moins que ce qu'on avait fait en 2019
pourquoi c'est pertinent de parler des
avions commerciaux alors qu'on parle de
défense ici parce que le sujet c'est
vraiment le sujet du recrutement c'est
le sud du recrutement en France c'est le
suivant en Europe c'est le sujet du
recrutement aux États-Unis également
on est vraiment rentré je pense dans une
aire de ressources rares sur le plan des
compétences et des personnels
l'année dernière la filière qui est
représentée par le GIFAS ici donc les
444 entreprises du GIFAS aujourd'hui à
recruter 18000 personnes c'est très
important puisqu'on a une filière qui
fait en gros 200000 personnes donc c'est
presque 10% de l'effectif pour autant de
très nombreux entreprises surtout des
petites non seulement n'ont pas réussi à
recruter selon tes avaient besoin mais
parfois le recrutement dans les grandes
entreprises a pu se faire au détriment
des petites vers les employés des
petites entreprises postulent dans les
grandes et ça aggrave la situation dans
les petites on s'en est rendu compte en
fin d'année dernière et c'est un sujet
qu'on essaie de travailler très
sérieusement en filière mais dans le
respect du droit du travail qui fait
qu'on peut pas guider et empêcher les
gens de postuler là où ils ont envie de
postuler cette année on prévoit
d'embaucher 25 000 personnes et on va
utiliser le salon du Bourget 2023 comme
un pôle d'attraction très très fort sur
l'embauche et le recrutement ça va se
faire au détriment d'autres secteurs
j'espère pas le naval évidemment
terrestre mais bon c'est effectivement
une situation où la ressource critique
c'est les compétences de ce point de vue
là Airbus on a un certain nombre de
dispositif on a le lycéenbus qui est une
institution ancienne à Toulouse qui
fonctionne très très bien et on attire
des jeunes qui ensuite viennent dans
l'entreprise sont vraiment très très
bien préparés et très content d'y être
on a ouvert l'année dernière une école
en fait une université une place
université avec l'aide de l'éducation
nationale
pour le cyber donc on a notre première
classe de 25 étudiants en cyber et on
est en train de recruter la deuxième
année et ça se passe très bien mais on
voit qu'on est obligé de s'occuper
nous-mêmes de la formation du
recrutement et de la formation beaucoup
plus que ça n'était cas par le passé et
ce qui me préoccupe et que je voudrais
partager avec vous c'est au delà de
l'attractivité de certains secteurs ou
par rapport à d'autres chez un bus on
n'a pas trop à se plaindre je parle en
tant qu'un bus on est l'entreprise la
plus attractive pour les ingénieurs
encore en de 22 pour en 2023 pardon
plusieurs années de suite donc on est
attractif mais
la difficulté qu'on a c'est quand on
embauche des gens les savoir-faire on
trouve les savoirs-être c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué aujourd'hui il faut des
gens capables de travailler à
l'international en équipe dans des
métiers contraignants avec des
compétences de relationnelles humaines
qui sont importantes et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la plus grosse
difficulté qu'on a quand on est devant
les recruteurs les équipes des
ressources humaines les CV qu'elles
écartent c'est rarement à cause des
compétences techniques c'est très
souvent parce que les personnalités les
les attitudes les comportements n'ont
pas été développés jusqu'à 18 20 ans
pour être capable de fonctionner dans
une entreprise de haute technologie de
coopération avec des contraintes
industrielles et ça c'est très très dur
pour un employeur de le changer donc il
y a un énorme travail de mon point de
vue à faire si on veut répondre à ce
problème là qui est très en bas
et très tôt dans la vie des jeunes à la
fois à la maison et à l'école et
redonner une dimension de développement
des compétences en savoir-être en
attitude en comportement en vie en
société et ça c'est vrai que pour nous
les entreprises aujourd'hui c'est
difficile
j'ai encore deux orateurs je demande à
chacun de
limiter son temps d'expression parce que
on a encore des conventions à prouver
Olivier Cadic merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président dans le
cas de notre mission en prévision de la
LPM pour la Commission concernant la
cybersé la cyber défense nous avons
visité la semaine dernière la DGA à
Rennes et le cybercommande donc en
compagnie de Michael Valley et André
gatelin on a été très agréablement
surpris ça va aller dans le sens de vos
propos et rassurer même par le niveau de
nos capacités présentés pour répondre
aux défis futur dans le cyber et je
voudrais prendre l'occasion pour vous
féliciter Thalès qui a réussi à
neutraliser un satellite de
démonstration en orbite dans le cadre
d'un défi lancé par l'Agence spatiale
européenne à des experts de la
cybersécurité de l'écosystème spatial ce
hacking satellitaire est une première
mondiale et je pensais que c'était
important de le souligner la principale
inquiétude dans dispositif est quand
même la vulnérabilité de la BITD en
matière cyber on nous fait une guerre
cyber les 14 affaires d'espionnage cyber
en 2021 dont 9 sont d'origine chinoise
en témoignent nos agresseurs sont à
l'initiative en répondant à mon collègue
Michael Vallet sur les défis en
ressources humaines concernant la cyber
président d'harmon a répondu par
anticipation une question que j'avais
prévu pour savoir ce qui était prévu
pour la BITD afin qu'elle ne soit pas le
maillon faible dans notre dispositif en
cyber mais j'aimerais poser une question
complémentaire votre par rapport à votre
réponse le département de la Défense
américain a lancé une initiative en
juillet 2022 pour un Cloud de défense
intitulé The Road trust reference
architecture qui prévoit d'associer des
grands noms américains comme Microsoft
comment analysez-vous cette initiative
pensez-vous que la LPM nous permet de
disposer d'un cloud de défense
suffisamment sécurisé au regard des
investissements que les États-Unis
consacrent à cet objectif je vous
remercie
je suis pas sûr que je sache répondre en
une minute à une question à une question
minute donc je vais je vais faire très
simple le mot cloud un peu comme le mot
cyber ou le mot sécurité ou le mot
système veut dire énormément de choses à
la fois en fait dans le domaine de la
défense les technologies de cloud
peuvent servir en infrastructure elles
peuvent servir sur un théâtre
d'opération pour déployer très
rapidement un poste de commandement en
technologie cloud ou même le Cloud de
combat tel que par exemple on va le
développer dans le cas du SCAF ou dans
le cas du mgcs sur les futurs sur les
futurs véhicules de combat donc ce sont
à chaque fois des technologies cloud
adaptées au marché de la défense donc
généralement des clubs privés
extrêmement sécurisées qui ne fuit pas
leur donner mais qui veulent dire des
choses très différentes on n'a pas à
rougir en France sur les technologies
cloud et sur leur sécurisation on est
sur des sujets qui sont assez différents
du Claude public sur lequel
malheureusement Microsoft amazon est
Google sont très en avance en termes de
Claude public sur le club de défense les
technologies qui ont développé par
exemple ce qu'on va faire sur le club de
combat du Scaff mais ce que l'on
développe déjà dans le cas de postes de
commandement Thalès a gagné à l'OTAN
donc il y a quelques années on est
parfaitement au niveau de ce que ce
qu'on rencontre dans le monde sur le
marché international
une vision un peu plus
négative des choses je pense que les
Américains ont une avance considérable
dans le domaine numérique et que ce que
les hyperskellers les Microsoft
AWS Amazon et Google ont acquis c'est
une avance qui est considérable dans ce
domaine technologique et qui a
évidemment des répercussions dans le
domaine militaire je pense qu'il est
absolument essentiel qu'on est la vision
du cloud de combat ou de l'utilisation
du de la technologie cloud de façon
souveraine pour les applications
militaires dans le futur et le terrain
de jeu se déplace énormément vers le
digital vers le numérique vers le cyber
puisqu'on a utilisé ce mot là donc il
est absolument essentiel d'avoir une
vision claire et des investissements et
des programmes et des projets qui
permettent de créer ou de développer
cette souveraineté dans ce domaine là
comme l'a dit Marc la réussite du volley
combat de Cloud de combat du Scaff et
absolument crucial il y a aussi une la
notion de vitesse qui est importante
puisque les Américains sont en train de
développer les standards du cloud de
combat du futur de l'OTAN il faut qu'on
ait qu'on soit à la table et pour être à
la table il faut avoir les technologies
et donc il faut les développer donc je
pense personnellement qu'on est très en
retard dans ces domaines là par rapport
aux Américains en particulier parce que
le domaine civil a avancé très très vite
à une échelle incroyable aux États-Unis
et qu'on n'a pas la même chose en Europe
et donc pour exister dans le même
militaire il va falloir être capable de
déterminer les couches qu'on veut
prendre qui nous permet d'avoir cette
souveraineté dans le domaine de
l'information militaire et de son
utilisation sans rêver avoir toute la
maîtrise de l'ensemble des briques qui
aujourd'hui mon avis un combat perdu
c'est ce travail qui est en cours de
définition pour lequel il y a eu un
certain nombre de mises en commun de
ressources à travers le Scaff et de
quelques autres projets il faut
absolument qu'on garde la détermination
et la vitesse et les investissements
dans ce domaine là où on aura perdu la
bataille de qui et comment se fait
l'échange d'information et demain celui
qui aura l'échange d'information qui la
maîtrisera aura gagné la guerre donc bon
en tout cas maîtrisera le jeu donc c'est
en ce moment que ça se joue et là il est
vraiment important qu'on mette les
ressources entre-européen ou quelques
Européens ensemble parce que l'échelle
d'investissement est juste absolument
énorme et c'est pour ça qu'on a perdu
dans le domaine civil la première
bataille du numérique c'est parce que
les Américains ont une échelle
d'investissement et d'exécution
incomparable avec ce qu'on a ici en
Europe dans le domaine de
l'investissement privé aujourd'hui on
parle de l'investissement public voilà
donc je pense que sur le domaine du
cyber comme on dit en anglais de Jerry's
out on est on n'a pas encore défini si
on allait y arriver ou pas il faut
surtout pas relâcher l'effort
merci dernière question Philippe Folliot
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
quand nous sommes présents sur les
grands salons internationaux nous
constatons que sur les stands de vos
concurrents il y a beaucoup de domaines
uniforme
et dans ce cadre je voudrais vous poser
la question est-ce que vous considérez
que les relations et l'engagement des
forces par rapport au soutien
vous paraît-il suffisant par rapport par
rapport à cela avez-vous une stratégie
peut-être pour avoir des cadres de vos
entreprises qui sont aussi réservistes
et qui puissent faire l'interface donc
avec nos forces armées pour faire de
telles sortes qu'ils puissent avoir un
appui un élément important parce que je
crois que c'est un enjeu essentiel par
rapport si vous permettez à l'équipe
France en la matière de pouvoir être
efficace et est-ce qu'il y a des
éléments et des stratégies y compris par
rapport aux actions civiles militaires
que nous menons qui peuvent être aussi
parfois une amorce et un début
d'interface par rapport à la
reconstruction des pays où vous
engagements post conflits et pour
lesquels au travers donc de
relation officielles ou de réservistes
que vous pourriez avoir ça pourrait
faciliter le fait que nous puissions
ensuite gagner si vous me permettez
après la phase du conflit la phase de
reconstruction et la phase économique en
la matière merci
je crois que vous avez beaucoup
d'uniformes simplement ils ont troqué
contre des abysses d'ailleurs autour de
la table qui est ancien militaire
voilà donc on a on a on a beaucoup
d'anciens des forces armés dans nos
industries tant mieux et d'ailleurs
quand on parle de ressources rares c'est
un sujet qu'il faut qu'on arrive aussi à
travailler très en amont avec les forces
armées notamment pour certaines
spécialités pour éviter
de mettre en concurrence finalement
l'industrie et les armées parce que elle
gère aussi leurs ressources humaines au
plus juste et donc c'est un sujet qui
qui est propice au dialogue et qui nous
et qui nous concerne d'ailleurs à ce
titre là on parlait de la réserve
industrielle la réserve opérationnelle
est extrêmement importante pour nous
parce qu'elles permettent de créer ce
lien entre nos personnels on va dire
civils et les forces armées et donc nous
encourageons dans nos entreprises en
général la réserve et les périodes de
réserve opérationnelle voilà bon après
vous posez monsieur le Center une
question sur le sous-tex finalement et
le soutien qu'apporte les forces armées
à nos campagnes à l'exportation je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ça se passe plutôt pas
mal en France
si je prends l'exemple du domaine naval
souvent dans des salons où souvent
autour de déplacement officiel on voit
un bateau de la marine nationale qui est
là et un équipage qui est très engagé
pour expliquer à tous les visiteurs
évidemment les équipements les soutiens
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire plus bien
évidemment mais aussi en prenant bien
conscience des impacts opérationnels que
ça peut avoir je crois que là aussi
c'est l'objet d'un dialogue permanent
qu'on doit avoir avec les forces armées
mais je tiens juste à dire que ce sous
texte est extrêmement important il est
d'autant plus facile pour nous d'être
performant à l'international que les
équipements sont utilisés dans les
forces armées françaises et force armées
françaises qui comme vous le savez c'est
pas ici que je vais le lire sont
extraordinairement engagés sur tous les
théâtres voilà ce que je voulais dire
juste sur sur ce commentaire sous texte
en tout cas on y est extrêmement attaché
juste rajouter une phrase sur le soutien
d'exportation pour dire comme comme l'a
dit Pierrick comme les que on peut pas
se plaindre et que il existe il est
vraiment très fort raison de plus pour
l'inscrire dans la LPM puisqu'on l'a dit
l'export est une part importante à notre
équilibre du modèle
après la question sur
finalement les les comment est-ce que
l'industrie participe à la à la à la
suite politique et industrielle d'un
conflit armé là je nous ramène nous
sommes un des acteurs qui voilà qui agit
et qui est sollicité mais en général
derrière le politique qui est le premier
à intervenir dans ces cas-là et qui nous
sommes en soutien évidemment autant que
de besoin
merci pour cette si vous aviez chacun un
amendement à proposer à LPM ce serait
lequel
on essaie de
une thématique au moins un point
particulier
je reviens sur le sujet de la compétence
c'est le
tout cela ne vaut que parce que on est
tous ensemble est capable de
convaincre nos jeunes générations de
venir travailler dans la défense alors
je sais pas si on peut le traduire dans
un abonnement mais en tout cas faire en
sorte que ce tout tout industriel est au
moins dans sa carrière à la quasi
obligation d'aller donner des cours dans
un lycée que
tout tout parlementaire et industriels
doivent ensemble aller dans une
université pour faire au moins une fois
par an un amphi retape sur la défense
voilà quelque chose autour d'une action
collective vers les jeunes générations
parce que finalement tout ce qu'on se
dit ne se fera que si ils viennent
travailler chez nous
tu es nul mais on a cru comprendre que
ça se passait pas très bien
Guillaume Faury
je pense que ce que la LPM montre c'est
que le nombre de sujets à couvrir et
absolument considérable et qu'il faut
arriver à être pertinent dans un nombre
de terrain de jeu qui sont absolument
énormes et dans chacun de ces sujets on
est face à d'autres forces en présence
qui ont une échelle bien supérieure à la
nôtre donc il faut se poser la question
à chaque fois de ce qu'on peut faire à
plusieurs
tout seul on va vite ensemble on va loin
il y a beaucoup de sujets sur lequel il
faut pouvoir aller vite et faire les
choses en National et la bonne réponse
il y a je pense de plus en plus de
sujets sur lequel il faut pouvoir
trouver des alliés avec lequel ou des
partenaires avec lequel ce
s'organiser s'associer pour partager les
investissements pour trouver l'accès aux
ressources et pouvoir des séries plus
longues et donc je pense qu'il faut
faire plus d'efforts encore que ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui avec nos principaux
alliés pour mutualiser les besoins et
donc pouvoir mutualiser les réponses et
les solutions et ça je pense pas ce que
ça passe dans un article malheureusement
c'est pas ça se décrète pas et on part
pas de nulle part il y a beaucoup de
choses positives qui se sont faites et
qui continuent à se faire mais je pense
que c'est la clé du succès à l'horizon
de 10 15 ou 20 ans
et le dernier mot G4 je vais renchérir
sur le point de pierre pour moi cette
concerne pas que les jeunes mais si
l'ensemble de leur représentation
nationale et d'une façon générale que la
nation défendent l'image de l'industrie
de défense pour tout ce qu'elle apporte
et tout ce qu'apporte la défense ça joue
sur bien sûr le recrutement ça joue sur
les financements ça joue sur l'ensemble
que l'on peut avoir de l'image de la
nation
écoutez je crois que c'est le travail
qui a voulu faire la commission
aujourd'hui et puisqu'on a souhaité que
cette audition soit rendue publique et
une manière générale les auditions de la
commission d'affaires étrangères de la
défense sont suivis à attentivement par
toutes sortes de public donc merci en
tous les cas de vous être prêté à ce jeu
de questions-réponses qui permet
d'éclairer le travail approfondi que
nous que nous avons démarré sur la
sur la LPM je rappelle du SAV à mes
collègues que j'ai transmis hier au
ministre des Armées conformément à
l'engagement qu'il avait pris d'y
répondre je lui ai transmis 86 questions
et maintenant 86 82 questions écrites
que les rapporteurs y compris de la
commission des finances aussi qui s'est
joué à nous 82 questions écrites
auxquelles nous attendons une réponse
écrite de telle sorte que nous soyons
bien en phase avant d'entamer à la fois
la discussion ici arctique par article
dans la Commission et venir en émissions
merci à merci merci à vous trois
nous vous souhaitons évidemment les
meilleures chances de réussite dans les
branches respectives qui sont les vôtres
que avec un certain nombre de collègues
j'essaie moins de mieux connaître
souhaite particulièrement bonne chance à
un avalgroupe puisque je crois
qu'aujourd'hui vous inaugurez votre
filiale et l'unique petit filiale grec
naval group elas donc
on a déjà les trois FDI on attend les
goin donc
je dis si on peut nous entendre si
l'ambassade grecque le ministre grec si
tous ces gens nous entendent et puis
évidemment bonne chance bonne chance à
vous tous et sachez que la que la
Commission d'affaires étrangères reste
évidemment très attentive à la dimension
industrielle car vous êtes le vous êtes
le trépied et les armées il y a les
politiques puis il y a les industriels
donc nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs
à vos succès et au fait que cette LPM
doit vous aider à aller plus loin
conserver cette force d'innovation et de
recherche de qui caractérise la BITD
vous l'avez dit vous êtes dans un milieu
de fortes concurrence les uns et les
autres et on l'a vu à travers des des
marchés récents certains ont été gagnés
d'autres ne l'ont pas été en tous les
cas nous sommes à vos côtés très
attentifs à ce que c'est industrie reste
l'un des fers de lance de notre sécurité
je rappelle régulièrement même si
certains n'y trouvent pas leur compte
que vous représentez quelque chose comme
200 000 emplois en France
ce qui n'est quand même pas une petite
affaire donc soyons vigilants bonne
chance on est à vos côtés
courte suspension avant d'attaquer les
conventions